this is jocko podcast number 337 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening gecko good evening
we had planned to take down an insurgent
cell known to be located in three or
four buildings in a village overrun with
sunni extremists
i was one of the four seals on the
outskirts making sure the area was clear
before establishing the command and
control position
suddenly through my grainy green night
vision goggles
i saw a family
a mom a dad a 10 year old kid and a baby
sleeping outside a shack on a two foot
high platform
this wasn't entirely unusual given the
middle of the night heat in iraq
families often slept outside
but something about this situation fell
off to me
i saw the father start to reach for
something instinct told me this was bad
i spoke firmly and clearly to the guy
behind me calling his name joel joel
joel so he would know
that i was about to make a move and
could cover me
and i held the iraqi man in my
crosshairs
ready to shoot him at any moment as i
rushed as fast as i could toward him
before he could grab what did turn out
to be a weapon
he was reaching for an ak rifle just as
i put my foot on his arm so he wouldn't
be able to point the weapon at me or any
of my teammates
then i quickly put my muzzle on his
chest and subdued him and enlisted
joel's help to properly detain him with
flex cuffs
i could have shot him at any time
but as i first approached him i didn't
know for sure that he was armed and my
instant and instinctive calculation made
me confident that i would be fast enough
to get him before he could take a shot
at me or anyone else if he did have a
weapon
it turned out that the ak was fully
loaded and he had three magazines
and after we got him cuffed his family
under our control and our target secured
we realized through our interrogation
process that he was in fact the number
two most wanted enemy in western iraq at
the time
so that right there
is an excerpt from a book
a book called never enough which was
written by
mike hayes who is a retired seal officer
who served 20 years in the teams which
included tours at team four team eight
team 10
and also a tour as the commanding
officer of seal team two
and in his career he deployed to south
america europe iraq and afghanistan
he also served in the white house as
part of the national security council
council under both george w bush and
barack obama
and
i actually did serve with him for a
short time in germany
when he was the operations officer and
we are lucky enough to have him
here with us tonight to discuss some of
his experiences
and lessons learned
mike
thanks for joining us man jocko great to
see you brother
great to be here yeah we haven't we
haven't hung out much since we were
playing combat water polo in germany
which was circa 1998
and you were stationed at unit two were
you the ops officer i was the assistant
ops officer but uh
close enough okay so you're the
assistant oh that's right co exo ops you
were the assistant office officer so
that you know what that made me right as
an incident i was like the assistant
assistant ops officer so we'd have these
games these water polo games did you
actually play water polo i didn't play
in college but uh man alive combat water
polo with you was one of my best
memories
i obviously sucked at water polo but i
was good at jiu jitsu even even then and
i used to more for me it was more just
water jujitsu
especially against the guys that
actually could play water polo the go
and there were some guys there's a
couple guys that played water polo in
college i don't know if you remember
that yeah there was a couple guys that
really needed to get taken out of the
game
or at least mitigate it as much as
possible
yeah i know i mean for people listening
the rules there's just really one rule
if you let go of the ball you're
supposed to let go of the person so uh
you know it was intense and uh i always
uh did my best to be on your team
all right on good times all right let's
uh let's let's get right into it let's
talk about you and
let's talk about where where you grew up
where so where'd you grow up you're a
new englander right yeah well dad was in
the navy so uh bounced around a good bit
but from ninth grade on portsmouth rhode
island what did your dad do in the navy
he was a combination a submariner out of
college and then supply officer so kind
of a joint career there and how long did
he do he did 20 years 23 years or
something like that
and so you were all over the place i was
until until ninth grade
where where were you up until ninth
grade i lived in mechanicsburg
pennsylvania guam you know just a couple
places around the around the us and
and then uh just was really happy to
settle down in in ninth grade onward and
call the biggest little state of rhode
island home
how long have you been guam for what
grades seventh and eighth grade
was that pretty
then what year was this now that was 83
to 85. so guam was
remote in 83 85 84. we'd get the super
bowl mailed to us like four weeks after
it happened you know
because i went to guam
in
1992-93 when they finally when they
started sending seals their own
deployment and it was
i mean
you were not
really connected i mean there's no
internet or anything so everything took
a while to show up there
it was a it was a
a very educational part of my growing up
you know there's a the the simplicity
it was awesome but at the same time you
definitely give up some of the
the the amenities of modern life did you
go to school out in town or did you go
to school on base went to a a private
catholic high school actually junior
high school high school okay yeah
seventh and eighth grade
so you didn't get like the the crap beat
out of you by the lokes oh no i did of
course i did
i got a friend that was at sdv
in hawaii but he grew up in hawaii
and he was actually at team three as
well but he said it was so it was rough
man growing up he was a halle kid in
hawaii it was rough man echo charles
commentary yes sir oh rough rough for
the howly kids i can't be it depends it
really depends for sure well this
particular guy who's a great guy
where i think he might have been
claiming a lot of it had to do with him
being howly i think it may have also had
to do with his mouth which was rather
large that is typically the case yeah
for sure oh classic
um
so
you know you mentioned that your dad was
in the navy but you you have a section
in here about your grandfather as well
and i'm just going to go to the book
here and read this because it's a pretty
awesome piece of history you say my
grandfather graduated from the naval
academy in 1940 and was nursing a
hangover in a bungalow on the pearl
harbor naval base the morning of
december 7 1941 when the japanese began
bombing
he was with seven others at the time and
when he heard the first wave of
something going on he knew he needed to
get in his jeep and go toward the harbor
back to his ship
none of the others would go with him
they all believed they were safer where
they were he told me the scariest part
was heading toward the ship driving past
a marine guarding the gate at 45 miles
an hour without stopping worrying the
guard would shoot him
my grandfather made it to his ship and
manned his battle station he was on
board that ship for the third wave of
attacks and tended to many of the
wounded that day
in the wake of the bombing he realized
that he didn't want to spend his career
on the ground or at sea
when he'd tell me this story he would
point up at the sky and say he wanted to
be up there
he put in a transfer to become a pilot
and after flight school as a world war
ii raged across the pacific he ended up
stationed in the aleutian islands doing
long long-range bombing missions from
the outermost islands and helping to
attack strategic sites in northern japan
he took over as the commanding officer
of his 35 plane bombing squadron at age
26 after his own commanding officer was
shot down
and he later served as a test pilot for
the navy's first helicopters and the
commanding officer of the navy's first
helicopter squadron during the korean
war
he ended his career as a professor of
naval science at holy cross and
commanding officer of the school's rotc
training unit
he taught me about causes greater than
self what it means to serve and how to
keep pushing yourself to get better
no offense bro but if anyone should have
written a book it sounds like it would
be the grand dad huh i agree
larger than life he's a real like
absolute hero
you know
it's i was blessed to be able to grow up
around a person that didn't say what do
you want to be when you grow up he would
always say who do you want to be
and uh you know there are a few of us on
the in the nation and on the planet that
know what it's like to
set your personal desire in a side and
assume risk for the nation i i grew up
with the stories of my grandfather who
did that quite regularly and it was
always inspirational and i'm
really thankful it unquestionably
made an indelible mark on on who i am
so he was the commander of the rotc unit
at holy cross
that's
that's that's that's awesome to think
you had a guy that was that did all that
did he fight in the korean war when he
was a helicopter pilot so he was
actually here at north island california
and as the as hu1 was the the unit name
and i just remember it because i can
still see hit a lot of his plaques that
he had on his walls which are almost
memorized in my brain but but uh in
korea what the navy would do is put a
couple helicopters out on some of the
frigates and the ships and then use that
to go fly search and rescue
and so he like like like those of us who
in leadership positions in combat he
didn't have to get into the cockpit and
go fly
but every time he went to visit the
troops and there was something that
happened he said told the the young jg
to step aside and he was going to fly
this one and i'll never forget one great
story that he told from korea about
you know being shot at on quite heavily
going in to rescue a pilot and just very
calmly looking at his co-pilot and uh
after this co-pilot was freaking out a
bit and saying sir they're shooting at
us they're shooting at us they're
shooting at us and and and of course i'm
sure my grandfather just ice in his
veins just said son
we're at war that's their prerogative
i was on a i was on a
going on an operation it was my first
deployment to iraq and we're driving in
a convoy and we're heading south of
baghdad and it was a long transit we had
we're going down the net off as a matter
of fact so it's a long haul a few hours
maybe even like four or five hours
but we get ambushed and a couple rpgs
some some small arms firing the rpg's
missed us one of them went over and i'm
in vehicle two and it was a long convoy
we had some a vehicle another type of
vehicle in the middle so we probably had
six vehicles so
the v the and you know we're driving
blacked out and it's at night and
we so we get so my vehicle we make it no
nothing happens to us at all and then
we see i the first thing i saw was i was
looking kind of outboard and i just see
an explosion which the first thing that
i saw i saw a couple tracers but then i
saw an explosion which was an rpg that
went high and then another one went low
and we just you know
kept driving
i think i think uh you know push through
was the typical call or whatever
and
and then
my platoon chief who's a freaking great
guy that he was in vehicle six so he's
the one that got to like watch the rpg's
near miss and all this stuff and he
comes up on the radio and he goes he's
like hey sir yo hey we just got ambushed
back here we took some rpg fired some
and and some and some freaking small
arms
and i came up on the radio and went
roger
and he got a big kick out of that uh
maybe i should have been more
understanding at the time but uh yeah i
gotta try and stay calm sometimes
empathy works and sometimes it doesn't
right
so you're uh so you're growing up you so
you do your high school years in rhode
island what uh what what sports were you
doing did you play sports yeah did you
know soccer basketball baseball you know
was very um you know average at all
three in a town that was in a state that
wasn't exactly competitive either so
oh that's that's a harsh uh statement
about poor old rhode island
and so you're just a decent athlete i
mean how tall are you six four
and you didn't play did you were you
good at basketball i was you know i was
decent but in college all my friends
were on the varsity team and i was like
man i can't hold a candle to these guys
and what about grades were you studying
hard i was i was a good student in high
school
were you uh what kind of music were you
listening to oh gosh wow that's a great
question so mid 80s it was like you know
rush a little quiet riot maybe uh
uh what else would that have been you
know
that pretty much dates it dude quiet
riot
uh that come on feel the noise is that
am i
or is that twisted sister man
i'm messing up my hair metal bands
and then
since your d since your grandfather
worked at holy cross you went to holy
cross was that pre preordained or how'd
that happen my family has a long history
with holy cross my great
grandfather is in the varsity hall of
fame class of 1910 and uh and so you
know
my grandfather
there's a lot of relatives who've been
there so
no one ever pushed the navy or holy
cross or anything on me it was more of
just a hey son here's what's out there
there's this thing called a four-year
rotc scholarship and uh you know
i just love for you to be familiar with
it and um you know i'll never forget my
grandfather and dad put me in the car
like summer
of junior year in high school and
driving me up to holy cross and and
actually meeting the major who was in
charge of the unit at the time
and that was a guy who to this day is a
great friend of mine joe dunford later
became the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff so uh you know holy cross has
is a storied institution with a lot of
history and i was it was a no-brainer
for me
then uh you show up there and you're
instantly you're you take an rotc
scholarship out of the gate that means
they're paying for college everything
that's pretty good deal yeah at the time
i was just thinking to myself as the
oldest of four this is a great chance to
not burn any cash and save money for my
younger three siblings to be able to go
to college and
you know it's it i thought i'd do four
years as some sort of a supply officer
and get out or you know be have great
leadership experience for four years and
then you recall we invaded panama in 89
there was a guy named john connors who
was killed on the patio runway john was
a worcester poly tech graduate but holy
cross rotc so my first exposure to the
seal teams was the memorial service in
the chapel at holy cross where the the
seal community came together and
remembered john connors and that left a
real mark on me but freshman year dude i
was
six four and i don't know about 105
pounds i don't know but i was there was
no way at that age i i even thought
about myself being capable of going
through seal training but then later on
uh as the years progressed and i i went
from one push-ups to one and a half or
something like that you know then uh
then
i i went to mini buds and and then
became what was was that your first
sort of knowledge of the seal teams yeah
first when panama happened yeah because
panama definitely influenced me as well
because i thought to myself
wait there's a war there's a war going
on as far as i was concerned there's a
war going on and i was
thinking to myself how is this happening
and i'm not there and how do i get there
asap and that's why i joined the navy
well you know for me it was not what
went through my head at that time for me
it was
more of like a become familiar with it
and set it aside for a couple years and
you know in rotc you spend a week in the
summer with the pilots a week with the
you know the submariners and the surface
guys and you try to figure out what do
you want to be when you grow up and you
know i had a great aviation cruise i
flew in an a6 off of the uss saratoga
and it was right after top gun came out
so it was like 92-ish or something and i
was like you know partying like a rock
star and thought i'm gonna go be a pilot
this is freaking awesome then i went to
three weeks of mini buds and became
perversely attracted with that challenge
is uh
so holy cross have you ever been to
notre dame before
i have yeah so notre dame i've been
there a few times and it you know like
the
females aren't allowed in the mail dorms
and you have for the if they are they
got to be out of there by 10 o'clock at
night like it's pretty strict
from a college
aged person perspective it's holy cross
like that as well it's not as strict the
uh
there were you know at this point maybe
i'm going to guess roughly 10 or 15
jesuit priests on as as professors when
i was in college it's less now but uh
you know there were some that would
would go out and enjoy a glass of wine
or more for uh but but they'd disappear
around 10 o'clock at night and
but it was it was a it was there's a
great relationship between you know the
the student body and the faculty
so now you're saying that you did summer
cruises
and for those people that don't know
this is when you're going to college
you're in rotc the navy will take young
college kids and send them out to get a
little taste of the different parts of
the navy so did you do a ship one just a
straight up ship board one i did for a
day you know and i was like this ain't
me you know so uh that's all it took on
that one that wasn't hard well did you
were did you actually go
like onto a ship somewhere that was on
deployment or what was that um you know
i think what we did was got helicoptered
from norfolk over to some frigate for 36
hours or something it was thank god it
wasn't longer and then what and then
what year was that after your freshman
year 91-ish 92-ish yeah then when did
you do the pilot thing what year was
that was between junior and senior year
okay so in between your junior's year
junior year and your senior year you get
the full-on
um top gun experience i did and then the
full on buds and experience after that
so that was in the same summer same
summer that was an optional three week
thing and i thought you know in order to
really figure out do i want to be a
pilot or do i want to be a seal i've got
to go do this mini buds thing and they
took 32 kids out of college for that
program
what what year was the mini buds it was
the summer of 92.
so you show up to many buds and what are
they doing this is three weeks long it
was a legit they they legit three weeks
one week of each of the three phases of
training and you know when you're going
through it you're like how does this
compare with the real thing
it was after going through the real
thing i look back and say we got a legit
full treatment for each of the three
weeks and i think nowadays they use that
sort of it's called something else now i
think it's called seal officer
assessment and selection and it's it's
something like mini buds but it's sort
of the selection and how they're gonna
figure out who gets to go was it like
that for for you guys
i it definitely was we came out with
like grades out of the 32 you know like
not grades as an academic but like just
an all-around score of how you did and
and uh you know i i remember having a
pretty high number and thought i think
i'll be probably this will stand me
pretty well if i applied to to circle
back and go to buds and
history has it i did and they took 16
guys out of rotc my year 16 guys out of
the academy so there are 32 officers
taken into the program and as you know i
don't know the number maybe 15 of those
made it through ultimately or something
like that was there any quid quitters
and mini buds oh yeah there were yeah
there were it was fun
it's just like okay don't let the door
hit in the ass on the way out you know
and and so this is now
1993 that you graduate from holy cross
and you get your um
you get selected
i mean the selection process for
officers now
is totally insane i mean it's insane
back then
but with all the hype around seals and
all that it's just ridiculous but still
taking 16 from rotc and 16 from the
naval academy
that's slim pickens
it was tough and the hard thing as a
rising senior needing to make a life
decision was that i knew that if i
applied for buds
i would not get my number two choice of
pilot because
you know once you work through and they
take the washouts who they don't pick
for seal training all the pilot slots
are gone so it was a little bit of a
gamble it was a lot of a gamble but like
anything in life go for what you want
and then you would have been on that
ship that you didn't like very much
yeah
and then you show up what buds class
were you 192.
192. so you show up for buds class 192.
how prepared were you you think
i was very prepared i wasn't the
far from the most gifted physical
athlete you know i mean friends that did
you know showed up and did 50 pull-ups
and i'd you know struggle with my you
know eight and a quarter you know or
something like that but you know six
four two thirty at the time i
like all i i ran real fast could swim
like a fish the oak horse was no trouble
for me pull-ups were my my downfall but
you know i i came in feeling pretty
strong
was there any
uh was there anything that really
challenged you
for me it really was the pull-ups it uh
but never to the point where
i wasn't i joke around about eight and a
quarter but i i just you know i just i
just knew i was gonna i was there for a
reason you know if something's worth
doing it's worth overdoing and i
prepared as well as i could
and and i just took it really seriously
when i went through and kind of limited
my my drinking when i was going through
buds at age 21 everybody's drinking like
a fish i was pretty serious about
recovery and and um just knew i needed
every advantage i could possibly help
myself with i uh when i went through
buzz i didn't leave the barracks really
yeah like i was a total nerd i would
sharpen my knife and polish my boots
like all weekend long and i didn't even
think about the recovery aspect i think
that's a new thing like the idea of
recovery i don't know i didn't really
have that i didn't really think of that
you didn't have guys walking around with
those big jug the gallon jugs of water
like that that was the thing in our time
just pump the fluids after the after the
day and for the weekend yeah i didn't
really have too much of that now i've
always thought that if you were
if you couldn't do pull-ups you're going
to have a problem with the o course
and it seems like you had problems with
pulse but you still didn't have a
problem with the o course dude i'm i'm
i've honestly i flew through the i was
always top five in the of course and you
sucked at pull-ups
that's really bizarre well i mean it's
just a different type of strength
pulling just a little bit laterally
sometimes you know it's just that dead
overhead up and down for pull-ups is a
little different than like rope climb
where you're at that a little bit of an
angle how were you good at rope climbs
too yeah yeah it was really good
that's we must just have some weird
genetic anomaly where pull-ups are hard
cause that's crazy right to be able to
do the old course in a in a top five
position and be suck at pull-ups that
seems crazy yeah i mean i can't explain
it
i can just tell you what i experienced
yeah well the cool thing about sucking
at pull-ups is you probably won't fail
buds because you suck at pull-ups right
you can fail you can get dropped from
buds for running you can try get dropped
from buds from swimming you can get
dropped from buzz for the o course but
for pull-ups you might get you know
teased basically
uh by the instructors during a pt but
yeah no you're not going to get dropped
yeah no it's it's very true it's very
true how many um
how many people quit or how many did you
start with and how many people quit we
started with 120 and 19 graduated
started with 120 and 19 graduated what
were you did anybody quit that you were
like dang how's that oh hell yeah you
know you you got guys that look like you
who walk in on on day one and you're
like man what am i doing here but uh you
know
guys just drop like flies and and um you
know my you remember in the beginning
they they assigned swim buddies you just
throw people in the pool and go swim you
know a mile or half a mile i can't
remember which was but it was just
swimming as fast as you can and with 120
guys in the pool you're crawling all
over each other and just doing
and and then they just pair up you know
number one and number two or swim pair
one number three and number four swim
part two and so on so myself and chris
cassidy were swim pair one and so chris
and i like lifelong friends from you
know day one of buds and
and the two of us just um we're always
had this uh fun healthy sense of talking
trash at each other and uh
and uh you know he ended up as the honor
man for the class and i i uh years later
went back to buds and i i told him that
i pulled all the records and
recalculated the math and uh at this
point he was an astronaut of course you
know and and i said hey i just got some
bad news for you i'm having your name
taken off the plaque and my name's going
up
uh so so but nothing really challenged
you made it through one shot one shot
honestly no major injuries or anything
like that dude it was like that or
nothing so i i really can honestly say i
never thought about quitting and i never
it was hard just like the rest of us but
just powered straight through yeah
um so then you get a sign to so it's now
1994 is it 94.95 right yeah and you get
to assign to team four did you speak did
you speak spanish prior to that i was um
almost a double major in spanish so good
in the books but never real at that
point in life not a lot of practical
you know spanish because that was
when we were coming up if you spoke
spanish you were going to team four yeah
pretty much guaranteed yep
um
so being a new guy at the team and i
have a good new guy story from your book
here
and uh we'll go to the book it says
another story again from my time is a
brand new seal the navy needed four of
us to test out some new equipment
i was voluntold to take part in the
exercise they took us in a boat two or
three miles offshore dropped us in the
water and told us to swim to the beach
stay for a few minutes and then swim
back to the boat together
it turned out that conditions were
unexpectedly harsh 40 knot winds nearly
eight foot high waves and the four of us
immediately lost each other unable to
see more than a few feet in front of us
man that's scary in its own right
i swam for what felt like hours before i
finally got to the beach and once i was
there i could not see my teammates i
waited and waited
but there was simply no sign of them
i figured maybe i had missed them maybe
had gotten slowed down by the waves
maybe they'd already made their way back
so i got back in the water and tried to
return to the boat even though i
couldn't see it
in my mind i had to complete the
assigned mission at all costs just keep
going this is what a seal has to do
i couldn't find my way back to the boat
because the harsh conditions i was using
my silver ranger compass to do my best
to swim a straight line of bearing to
the planned link-up point
but it didn't work
i realized i must have drifted much more
than i expected i couldn't see back to
the beach either for a few hours i was
basically lost at sea wearing the other
three more experienced seals would think
i was a total screw-up
i had broken a fin strap and at one
point i was startled okay scared when i
was moved about 10 feet in the water
bumped hard by a massive sea mammal i
imagined that no one would ever find my
body and everyone in the seals would
think i must not have been a good
swimmer despite entering buds training
with one of the fastest swim times in
the history of the program and along
with my swim buddy chris cassidy coming
seconds away from the fastest ever two
mile swim in buds
finally the boat found me and picked me
up and i was quickly
exerted for being stupid enough to make
the swim back out to sea
my three teammates had ended up down the
beach from where the current had taken
me just a bit too far away from me to
see them and they stayed on the beach
until the boat came for them knowing
conditions were too miserable
to even attempt to head back i'd put
myself at risk for a training exercise
because i confused doing the hard thing
with doing the right thing my decision
was far too risky to make sense even as
a confident and capable swimmer
there's so many little lessons in that
one right there that little story and by
the way so your book is filled with a
bunch of lessons and obviously i'm just
reading um excerpts from it
and and this this chapter was choosing
the hard path and doing the hard thing
and of course everything's a dichotomy
and you can do things where you go too
hard but uh man
i can't even imagine you with your
silver ranger which is for those of you
that don't know it's a little compass
that you used to navigate on the land
and you you probably had it with you for
like e or some whatever
and you actually pulled this thing out
you're trying to swim a bearing which is
literally impossible to do
like this is totally ridiculous and what
i what i love about this and this is so
true
the main thing you're worried about
you're lost at sea for hours you're
getting pushed around by sea animals the
main thing you're worried about is
looking like a loser from your teammates
and being a bad deep guy
that's exactly right you know i i still
vividly remember being you know pushed
this you know eight or ten feet or so in
the water and just thinking okay this is
gonna be the end but the worst thing is
people are just gonna think i was a
terrible swimmer and it's just not what
you want it's not the look you want i
was like no i'm a good swimmer please
don't think that you know so yeah
there's a million lessons in there you
know so you know this well when you when
you write a book if you if you uh if
you're the president of your own fan
club by definition you don't have a book
you know and and so sharing these things
where we uh you know didn't make good
decisions or or in retrospect were were
actually stupid i think that's where the
learning is and that's what i tried to
do in the book
uh you you as a new guy meaning this is
the universal you me you all of us as
new guys man you do some dumb dumb
things
and this is a classic example of
like this is all the other guys that
were experienced were like hey we're not
swimming back out are you kidding me
we'll all die and you of course hey
that's what the mission is we're going
to go and do it
well a little bit too it's an
interesting thing i'd be interested in
your perspective on this but you know
growing up in the teams before 9 11 it
was mission mission mission at all costs
post 911 our community got much better
at saying you know what there's new
information
let's incorporate new information on
what's going on let's think about risk
is the risk worth the reward and
constantly reassessing that risk you
know it's it's uh it became okay
to turn around on a mission in iraq or
afghanistan and say hey you know what
the risk profile just changed massively
we'll we'll come back another night for
the this group of terrorists there's
this risk is not worth assuming and
let's not do the mission and and when i
was growing up and when you were growing
up we'd be excoriated for not doing the
mission
later on we were held up as smart
yeah um well there was there was a big
difference you know when we were coming
up before the war started we were
literally training for the big mish
singular like hey you're going to do
this one mission we didn't know what it
was but that's what we were training for
and yeah there was no way it didn't even
seem like a feasible idea that you would
turn around on a mission or not complete
the mission and then yeah obviously as
the war kicked off and once we started
to get combat experience for our
generation it was like oh this doesn't
make any sense oh the risk is too high
oh the enemy has what well we're not
going to get him then and
yeah
that's something that we had to learn
just as our forefathers had to learn and
it's unfortunately one of those lessons
that
it it's almost like we well we had to
relearn it you know uh i wrote about
this in leadership strategy and tactics
we used to set up this training scenario
in in
mount
or south or whatever you want to call it
the urban training where the guys would
be clearing
like down a building down a hallway and
there'd be we'd have a barricaded
shooter at the end of the hallway and
everybody that ended the hallway would
get riddled with paintball and get put
down
and you'd see
unfortunately just about every leader
would fall victim to us two more guys go
they get mowed down two more guys go
they get mowed down and and then you
know finally after
you know three quarters of the tasking
is laying dead in the hallway we'd say
hey man take a step back and think about
what's happening what are you doing it
does this make any sense
and they would have that's what they
have to do is they'd have to learn to
detach and take a step back and go oh
this is obviously bad and i shouldn't
continue to do this so yeah that's
definitely a lesson that we learned and
that we had then to pass on to the next
generation of seals to to make sure they
understand that
quitting
is an option
and you know you don't quit from a
strategic perspective but with whatever
tactic i'm using right now is going to
cost us lives or get people killed or
doesn't make any sense i got no problem
saying up i was wrong this is a bad move
we're not doing it anymore totally agree
and it's a lot of people ask me how does
your business career now that i've been
retired for 10 years and helped
run the operations for vmware a really
large software company
you know the the applicability is the
exact same
it's hey we have a certain amount of you
know capital to invest do we invest it
in in place a or place b or c and and
wait a minute you know what we're
getting feedback from the market that
our original choice wasn't quite right
are you going to keep trying to invest
your way through and throw bad money
after good money after bad a bad path no
you're going to make a decision some
costs are sunk let's go try something
different and and quickly dynamically
assess and so the parallels between
business and the seals are
in the military writ large are really
really perfect yeah i i often end up
talking to companies and that's the
exact example i'll use is hey we tried
this marketing campaign it's not we're
not getting the roi we expected
let's put more money into it okay and
they still don't get the roi we're
expected okay let's put even more money
it's it's the same thing as sending guys
down a hallway to get shot up awesome
so
you you so you get to team four that's
kind of an example of team four
um
what else was going on at team four when
you got there do you get do you get put
right into a platoon
i was relatively quick maybe six months
or so of kind of like schools and
individual time but yeah did you go to
so you went through stt at the team or
was it at the team okay so so your team
is running stt was that a good course of
instruction it was it was good you don't
know what you don't know at that age and
that's that that time in life you know
but uh look everything was learning at
that point learning what to do sometimes
learning what not to do
uh you know we um
but but immediate exposure to what was
going on i remember in demolition
training being at fort ap hill one range
over from us there were uh four marines
that were uh in a demolition accident
and and basically vaporized and um it
was terrible and and so what was the
accident there was um something called a
meekly charge it was like a line charge
and these it went low order and they you
know collected all the c4 and put it in
a pile and then went to burn it but
forgot that there was this little thing
called the booster in the c4 and so when
they when because you can burn c4 as
everybody as you know but not everybody
necessarily does and and that caused it
to go high order and uh and so you know
right right away we're exposed to you
know real situations and so lots of uh
like like you know a lot of the the
biggest learning comes from the hardest
situations
what uh what schools did you go to as a
new guy officer
well you know it's funny one of my
greatest friends in life warren
nickerson was the operations chief and
as a brand new instant i remember
walking in and saying all right chief
nick the only question i have is do i go
to free fall and then sniper or sniper
then free fall and he's like shut up new
guy you got some dog and ponies for you
so you know so i was you know hitting
the road doing you know the dog and pony
shows and all kinds of stuff but i you
know i i went to you know at the time it
wasn't like you could get right into
free fall school so it took me three or
four years to be able to get there and
so i i don't even my schools were so
unremarkable at that time that i don't
even remember what they were yeah i know
as a new guy i got sent to like uh well
i was very lucky that i got sent to the
comm school on the east coast which was
awesome but other than that it was like
demo driver school and just
here's how you chain up the trailer to
the vehicle and stuff like that yeah
just complete new guys schools it was
freaking horrible yeah and then you get
put into platoon a system tune commander
yep assistant platoon commander
and uh
how's your work up you're doing a six
month
you you know you're doing a six-month
deployment at this time team four
deploys to south america yeah it was
deployment was to panama and then from
there just a lot of jsets joint combined
exchanges for training where we we
bounced around and you know we trained
you know in el salvador you know chile
peru just the local
operational forces that were similar to
ours and um
and it was just a big you know
a big
bunch of fun it's it's there just wasn't
it wasn't there was no real
real stuff going on but uh lots of
learning how was how was your
you know what would you feel like as a
as a new guy officer if you were talking
to yourself when you were younger you're
talking to a young uh ensign or
lieutenant jg that's rolling into a
platoon right now
what would your
what would your advice be
look i think one of the things that that
young officers always wrestle with is
how to walk the line between
being a leader when a leader is needed
to step forward but at the same time
really have the humility that a lot of
other people know a lot of things that
you don't know and to me that's what
makes the team special is is when you
think about
how you make decisions and who makes
decisions we just grow up with that just
built into who we are and and and that's
really
uh you know the the the thing you test
is when do i step forward and say all
right guys
shut up lock it on we're going this
direction and when do you kind of step
back like like you you a spouse in a lot
of your work is lead leading from the
rear is okay
yeah
no one ever expects uh the seal leader
to say hey lead from the rear right yeah
are there times you gotta lead from the
front yes absolutely if you're doing
something that dangerous or something
that's horrible or something that's even
monotonous sometimes you got to step up
and say all right i got this
um but yeah well if i if i have the
opportunity and someone on my platoon or
my team wants to step up and lead
no problem go for it i like to say uh i
like to try and lead with minimum force
required right well you know we i i
think there are a couple great points
here first of all i always say that l
and seal stands for lazy right and like
we we find the easiest path to go
achieve the goal because that gives you
more time effort and energy for the next
problem or lets you rest and recover for
the next problem but uh you know it's um
like in business we're always thinking
about succession planning and the only
way you're gonna get your second line
ready to be the first line is if the
first line can take a step back and let
the second line be the first line so the
only thing you need to do if you're in
the leadership position and what i what
i try to do now i think it's one thing i
do decently is to step back and let
other people make the decisions and only
weigh in if and when needed
most importantly it's the process does
the process to make decisions make sense
is it thinking about like the seals or a
meritocracy as you know is who cares
where the idea comes from you get all
the ideas on the table you find the best
idea and the best idea wins and that's
the way you're going to go do the
mission and that's exactly the way we we
need to operate and often do operate in
in business yeah and and of course this
doesn't mean you let the second string
you know run off the cliff but you can
let them bump into the guard rails and
get a little dinged up and they're going
to learn from that put some bondo on
there and they'll be all right
um but a lot of times people are
paranoid they don't wanna take any risk
at all and think that oh you're gonna
make a mistake it's like hey yeah
they're gonna make mistakes and that's
how they're gonna learn dude it comes
down to comfort in your role right i
mean it's it's if
i describe careers in three phases the
first phase is getting really good at
something whatever it is doctor lawyer
seal whatever the second phase is trying
to show the world you're really damn
good at what you've chosen and that
third phase which many people don't get
to
is being so confident that you are good
that you no longer need to prove it to
anybody and that's what lets you step
back i think when i see in in the
business world the the people the
leaders who don't step back
what i see is oftentimes a lack of um a
lack of confidence that
that um
that makes the person feel like if
they're not in front of the room making
the decision then then they're not seen
as the one in charge and so it's real
really i think a failure of leadership
when you can't step back yeah i had uh
one of the things i used to teach the
jos
was you have nothing to prove but
everything to prove and the nothing to
prove part is
hey i don't care how we build this
palette i don't care you know i don't
care
who goes on this operation i don't care
what route we take in like there's a
bunch of little decisions that are gonna
get made that if your platoon makes them
it's perfectly fine and you don't need
to prove well my way of getting to the
target would be a little bit more
efficient than yours or my way of
building we might not get our feet wet
yeah yeah just like all these little
things where sometimes that insecure
junior leader feels like they need to
prove to everyone that they're in charge
and you don't you have nothing to prove
you're actually in charge you're de
facto in charge and that's fine you
don't need to prove it what you do need
to prove is that you're gonna listen
that you're gonna that you're gonna pay
attention that you're gonna make the
right decisions at the right time that
when it is time to weigh in you're going
to do something smart not something rash
so
yeah all good things to think about
speaking of
not being rash
here's a little scenario you talk about
in the book my platoon was once training
at the altahama am i saying that altamah
ultima altamaha altamaha river in
georgia
and we had an enthusiastic seal named
max
we were carrying kayaks with a good
amount of gear inside trying to find the
most convenient way to transport guns
paddles and sensitive reconnaissance
equipment that had to stay dry as we
waded through the shallow water
suddenly max very calmly stopped and
said to me mr hayes there's a gator on
my leg
his calm demeanor in the face of such an
alarming statement caused me to doubt
him until he lifted his leg out of the
water and i saw a three to four foot
baby alligator had indeed had indeed
latched around his knee max to his
extreme credit did not overreact he
stayed calm certainly calmer than i
would have been and took deep breaths
until the alligator decided to open his
mouth and let go max was unharmed other
than four bite mark ii scars many of our
enemies are not as cooperative as that
baby alligator ended up being which is
why our reactions to situations are so
important the smartest seal isn't the
one with the greatest raw intelligence
it's the one who has the best
and quickest reaction to the problem
the seal who can quickly assess and
decide the best course of action is the
one i want on my team not the seal who
gets emotional and lets his feelings or
his fears get in the way of pure
rationality
i said in chapter one that i would take
someone with hunger over someone with
greater ability every time i'd also take
someone who reacts well over someone
with greater raw intelligence
you want both intelligence and control
but in the stressful moments control
matters a lot i would love to find
people who are smart enough to predict
the future but i haven't come across
many of them so i need people who react
well no matter what the future turns out
to hold no matter the context the
importance of having
good controlled reactions to surprising
situations can never be overstated
so there you go
freaking gator chomps on your leg
yeah you know you know the saying you
don't have to out swim your buddy you
just have to excuse me you don't have to
outswim the shark you just have to
outswim your buddy
so you know it's like should i go on a
dry land and get away from this guy uh
yeah i remember that situation very well
but in all sincerity it is the
expression
calm breeds calm excitement breeds
excitement you've been shot at and
rocketed enough to know that
anytime you're not calm you are just
using a motion that could be used to
solve the problem yeah
um
do you think that the that buds weeds
out some of that
it's a good question i think to some
degree but not perfectly yeah it's
definitely not perfect because i know
you and i both have seen plenty of team
guys go freaking like this guy max is a
great example of
like the comm cool collected seal that
you want in your platoon either in
charge of your platoon or one of your
machine guns in your platoon having a
guy like that is awesome
having somebody that's just
loses their mind is absolutely horrible
i think that's one of those traits that
you can learn though i'm sure you're
asked a similar question that i am
frequently which is uh talk to me about
what's innate leadership what are you
born with and what can you train through
time yeah i think that calm is a thing
that you can learn and train through
time yeah would you agree 100 and you
know i i got really lucky in that the
last tour that i did was run and trade
it out on the west coast and so i got to
run this freaking leadership laboratory
which was
i honestly think it might have been
the greatest leadership laboratory
that's ever existed in the world
that's what i think uh
just to be able to put these guys in
these stressful situations with so much
on the line and look it wasn't life or
death no so i guess combat is an even
better leadership laboratory except for
in combat you can't take a guy and put
him through iteration after iteration
after iteration because he's dead if
he's bad so you can't really it's not a
laboratory it's a real world test is
combat a better real world test than
than
going through training yes it is but the
training that we had was really crazy
good it was realistic it was hard
and you would see guys
develop these traits you would watch
guys
you'd see them and and you'd put them in
a situation and they'd lose their mind
or they'd start getting getting panicked
or they'd start freaking out about
something
and you'd see everything would fall
apart their platoon would fall apart
and then maybe you know the next time
you s you know you so you debrief them
hey listen man when you start yelling
and screaming on the radio no one's
listening to you anymore it's not
getting through to anybody they can't
make sense of what you're saying
you need to calm down you need to think
about what you're going to say simple
clear and concise language so you brief
them on that and then the next time
maybe they start getting excited you go
hey man hey fred come here
take a rap off think about what you're
going to say what are you going to tell
your platoon to do i'm going to tell
them to get oh no hold on what are you
going to tell him to do i'm going to
tell him to get hold on what do you tell
him to do
i'm going to tell him to move to
building 34 okay now come up on the
radio and just say that or just yell it
just just put the word out and then
you'd see the guy do it and you could
see
that
they would learn so yes you can
absolutely learn this stuff as long as
you're humble enough to uh as long as
you're humble enough to take criticism
and and and assess yourself and so
there's a bunch of things that
that you can improve at look there's
some things that you can't improve at
right there's some genetic things that
you have
that you can't improve
um there's another thing i wrote about
leadership strategy in texas had a guy
coming through he's a task unit
commander
super smart guy
good tactician
the voice of a mouse right so when it
came time to put out word
you know like to tell everyone what was
going on
he just didn't have he couldn't project
his voice at all and so i'm talking to
him like hey man listen
you got to start you got to start
putting the word out and in my mind i'm
thinking you know
maybe this is just maybe i'm just super
biased towards being loud because i have
a loud voice maybe i'm just biased and
so i'm watching him and
i can see he's trying to put out word no
one can hear him it's a problem
so i say hey man if you don't start
upping your volume people can't hear you
i don't even know if you can do this job
which is a real like
horrible thing to tell someone this
guy's a task unit commander he's been in
the teams for 12 or 15 years or
something this is a senior guy and now
i'm telling him hey you can't do this
and
then the next iteration
i'm watching him
and he's got to make the call and he
grabs like big mouth bill
in his platoon or one of the platoons
it's like hey bill tell it when to get
to building 34 now and bill
and i was like oh cool problem solved so
you gotta you've got some things that
you can't get better at you know some
people aren't articulate talking in
front of a crowd okay cool hey echo
you're good in front of a crowd you put
the word out to the troops or some
people can't simplify a problem so it's
like hey mike i'm having a hard time
getting through this can you simplify
this thing so everyone can understand it
so there's some things that you're going
to naturally
not going to be great at
put your leadership team together where
you've got some people that are good at
that and then be humble enough to say
you know what mike's a lot better at
simplifying things than i am and echo's
a lot more articulate than i am so i'm
gonna have mike figure out the problem
and i'm gonna have echo talk about it
and we're gonna be good to go i'm gonna
sit back and and just try and get these
guys what they need um
so there are things that you can not get
better at or you can usually improve
them a little bit but you might not
become an expert at them but there's
there's definitely some things that you
can absolutely improve on and being calm
and being able to detach and take a step
back is
most certainly most certainly one of
them
um
so that was your assistant platoon
commander was there anything else was
you got one story on that deployment
about kind of getting help was this when
you got held up at gunpoint yeah talk us
through that so in 1996 uh we
we were with a squad in peru squads
eight seals so it's myself and seven
uh guys and you know we were just
training the peruvian seals nothing
crazy and um
the i will say that in those days the
leader of the shining path sandero
luminoso which was a terrorist
organization was in jail about a mile or
less than a mile from the peruvian seals
compound
so
we were
likely you know watched or people knew
that there was somebody in country
helping the peruvian seals but my myself
and my lpo stayed back in lima for just
a day
while the rest of the guys flew forward
to iquitos peru which was deep in the
jungles of the amazon and
and we were just literally out to dinner
one night driving back from dinner
unarmed and two cop cars pinned us in
really really quickly
jumped out with uh three or four three
three or four guys were armed you know
rifles and
um you know basically opened the door
held me at gunpoint threatened me with
execution and and they they drove us
around and basically interrogated us
asked us a bunch of
questions that nobody ever really wants
to answer you know how you want to be
tortured how you want to be executed how
do you want to die you know and and and
a lot of worse things than that i had a
point where i could have jumped out of
the car that my lpo ken needham was in
the back of this suv i was in the middle
seats
and i could have jumped out when the car
was going 40 or so saved myself and i
very very vividly remember
i can never ever jump out of this car
because i couldn't live with myself
if i bailed on ken and i lived and they
killed him
just not who i wanted back to my
grandfather said who do you want to be
so you know we learn never bail on your
swim buddy and i was not i was fortunate
after that incident because i could
answer
really really truthfully knowing that in
a life and death situation that i would
not bail on my swim buddy so
it was a a lot of learning at a at a
young age how did you get out of that
scenario you know i did what i
uh what i would have wanted victims to
do if i were in the other role
don't look at the victims so we can't
identify excuse me don't look at the
assailants so that we can't identify
them and the the threat goes down and
and just be compliant and answer to our
previous part of the conversation around
calm i was so uber calmly these you
would never think that i was even one
percent remotely worried about the
situation i was in
i in spanish i was like hey we're
economists we're desk workers we work at
the the embassy and you know we were
just out to dinner these things happen
all the time if we get it you guys need
the car take the car we have insurance
go take it it's all it's all you
and um
and just really totally mellow answer
these questions and i think these guys
just figured out these guys aren't a
threat these guys these guys can't
possibly be seals so uh so they drove us
around and after the interrogation of
about an hour they brought us out of the
car at gunpoint and i was like okay this
is the point where they either pull the
trigger or they don't myself and ken
just kept walking because i remember
very vividly thinking hey a 10 foot shot
is harder than a zero foot shot
you know maybe they'll miss an organ and
so i just quickly put space between me
and the the guy who had a gun and at the
point he just i wasn't looking backwards
so i can't tell you what he was doing i
was just ready to be shot and um
and uh they never pulled the trigger
doesn't sound like a very nice last day
in the in the city of
there i have not been back to lima
and so that's what you did on that
deployment you travel around this is
pre-911 you're traveling around you're
training other forces
um
and and then what happens after that
after that tour is that that's when you
go to germany went to dli for learning
german for nine months uh then ended up
you know just going over to germany oh
you went to dli first huh i did yeah
yeah
so you speak three languages then i well
no
no i i'm still working on english
so you go to dli and then you come over
to germany this is where i meet you 97
98 98 because i went i basically got
done with ocs i showed up at seal team
two and immediately went over there um
and
it was
the master chief there who
was one of my platoon chiefs
and apparently the conversation went uh
the commander over there or or the ops
officer said hey we need like we need
someone to come and help out with ops
and they were sending they're sending
this ensign
and they're saying oh these guys are
sending us team two centers a damn
ensign like what good is this guy gonna
do and then
then the master chief sees my name and
goes wait a second i know this guy he
said you say that name again henson
willing we want this guy over here and
so uh sure enough i showed up and we
played water polo
yeah i don't know what we did beside
that if in all truth uh we probably
filled out some forms and almost like in
the almost the pre-computer days you
know so i don't know what in the world
we possibly we weren't deleting email in
those days well i'll tell you a funny
story we went to we did some big joint
exercise
and
the the skipper
at the time he's like all right jocko
you're gonna go forward and we're gonna
you're gonna run the the tactical
operation center and like
you know these days we think of a
tactical operation center you know we're
talking plasma tvs and satellite links
and internet you're talking you know
like a star trek looking scenario i [__]
you not we went on this mission and i
fit this quote tactical operation center
into one single rucksack i had like a 77
radio or something i had a bunch of maps
i had some like i thought i was squared
away because i had you know like some
overlays for the maps and then
how much the world changed between that
time because so this is 1998
well i i literally had the tactical
operation i mean this isn't a big
exercise a big giant joint exercise that
was taking place all over europe and i
had a little you know we had a little
the the seals there had a little role in
this exercise but it was a big exercise
a lot of stuff going on and i literally
had the entire tactical operation center
set in in my rucksack
that's uh that's scary that's some good
times right there
um
so then how how long were you how long
do you spend in germany for two years
and and that was the the bosnia kosovo
days and so there was some good learning
there too and i felt like
i would be a better platoon commander if
i went overseas at a role like that for
two years and honestly those two years
really set me up to be in my in my
opinion a much better platoon commander
when i got to seal teammate in 99 yeah
and and just kind of had some epic
leadership over there too the unit that
you were at
um i mean those leaders are just
incredible leadership over there
incredible really really strong rick
smithers yeah
yeah just great guys that
awesome times um any major so so when
you say oh there's there's lessons that
i learned or there's things that i got
from that deployment i mean is it just
learning what it's like from the other
side when you're on deployment yeah it's
it's um taking a look at a sealed
platoon and saying what is the effective
employment of a seal platoon when you're
in the platoon you're a little bit
uh i don't want to say biased you have a
narrow view
you know and so understanding the
difference between what success and um
you know and i wouldn't say failure but
like some average performance is was
really important to me because
you know
hearing having the opportunity at a
young age a junior seniority to see the
senior leadership say hey that was
really awesome or what the hell are
those guys doing
just those statements themselves carried
value
i was um
in training sell it seal team once i was
like an e5
and i went on my first trip where i was
kind of like the trip lead and it was to
florida
to herbert field florida and we put a
platoon out in the field for a recon and
whatever and like they they flew down
there went right in the field they might
have even jumped into the field but
anyways they go down there they go right
in the field and of course i was there
on avon getting the target set up and
all this stuff
and then they get done with the
operation and we pull them out of the
field and now they've got whatever it is
three days
in fort waldon beach florida and i'm
like but it was the first time that i
saw a platoon from the outside
and i was like oh my god this is gonna
be a problem like there's no way these
guys are gonna get through
three days of
liberty here we this is gonna be crazy
and i remember that was the first time i
was not in a platoon because when you're
in a platoon you don't you're just like
oh we can go out now cool oh we're done
with our op cool we're gonna go out and
do whatever we want in wherever we are
and that was like the first time i saw
it from the outside and it was a good
learning lesson for me yeah you know
like we often say now it's you don't
know what you don't know and so how do
you
take things from that unknown unknown
quadrant and make them known like
whether it's the seals or in business
all of the risk and all of the
opportunity is in that unknown unknown
quadrant so how do you get into that and
identify it and pull it back out so we
didn't realize it in those days but
that's what we were doing
yeah
yeah it's uh
if you that's another lesson
another uh
should say a
reiteration of the lesson of to take a
step back and see something because when
you're in that platoon you don't you
don't and you've been on deployment
before you knew what it was like to go
on deployment but you were in a platoon
and so you don't quite know the
perspective of not being in the platoon
and not understanding what that looks
like from the outside and not
understanding
what it looks like when there's some
kind of an incident and how much that
disrupts everyone and how much it hurts
our reputation as seals
you know that's something you know when
you're in a safety and someone gets in
trouble you're like oh fred got in
trouble
you don't think about it from you know
what does the fleet think of that what
is that army commander that's there
think of those things you just don't
well at least i didn't i had you know i
was young dumb and and
uh well just young and dumb i guess you
don't need to finish that
um
so you wrap up there you wrap up there
and then where you go seal teammate took
over as a platoon commander and um
did work up and then deployed down to
kosovo so what year is it now
so
99 i moved back to virginia beach and
take over as a platoon commander
and um when you get there
how are you how are you feeling how you
feeling you're getting your platoon dude
so great it's like finally like i'm
ready you know it's been a year of like
put me in coach and then you're finally
in and it's just off to the races and
just you know
you remember the feeling well i'm sure
it's it's um
it's everything that's cracked up to
being more and so you said you this is
that team eight yeah and so now you guys
are
basically fighting to try and get to go
back to uconn yup and go to
kosovo bosnia whatever's happening in
that theater because that's the only
show in town that's the only show in
town but we made it back and and you
know we
did a deployment there where we were
doing you know small four or six man
special reconnaissance missions and you
know we'd go out on three or four day
ops and then we'd stand qrf for three or
four days while another a sister part of
the unit would go out and then um and
then we'd have three or four days off so
we were actually in quite a a regular
predictable cycle while we were overseas
you talk a little bit about one of these
operations here in the book
here we go i was in kosovo in 1999 in
the middle of winter leading a small
surveillance team in the mountains just
a few hundred meters from the serbian
border freezing cold temperatures the
darkness of night howling winds and both
kosovar serbian and albanian armies
somewhere in that same snowy terrain
weapons ready looking for an enemy to
fight
as we suffered through the elements the
sun soon to rise we knew we needed to
find a place to rest and hide for the
daylight hours from our vantage point
halfway up the side of a mountain
struggling to maintain our balance on
the steeply sloping ground
we could see a natural line of drift
below railroad tracks a 10 foot wide
patch of flat ground a path that could
that would have called out to anyone as
the comfortable place we should
naturally set up camp
of course we wanted to move down there
i remember a young guy on our team
incredulous that we could even be out in
this kind of weather
humans can't survive in this he said
it's miserable
the temptation to head down toward the
easier path and the more comfortable
sight was real
but if it was calling out to us we knew
it would be calling out to anyone who
happened to be coming that way
going down there would make us more
visible more vulnerable and more likely
to run into trouble
so we set up camp a couple hundred year
meters up the steeply angled slope and
sure enough within an hour and just a
short time before sunrise what looked
like the entire albanian army marched
straight down that natural line of drift
had we been camped there they would have
found us for sure
doing the uncomfortable exhausting thing
the hard thing
saved us that day
so those are the type of operations you
were doing
you're a great reader by the way
yes did you did you guys do winter
warfare in your workout we did
and this was after i guess team eight or
sorry team two had sort of given up the
the the the lock they had on winter
warfare they they did and you know it
was all of you know four or six weeks or
something like that in the colorado what
are they 13 000 or 14 000
foot peaks and so we did you know slept
in snow caves and
attempted to get good at telemark but
certainly get good at snowshoeing and
we did all the winter work up and and it
really paid off because those operations
in kosovo were sometimes really
miserable from a weather perspective and
and and then on that particular passage
you just read i mean i just very vividly
remember thinking like if we would have
given in and done the easy thing there
we probably would not have survived we
at a minimum would have been captured
and interrogated
the so you you did a full six month
deployment down in that ao yes and
you're doing pretty much three days on
in the field three days on qrf and then
three days off yes it's forward stage
the qrf and sleep in a humvee for three
days or you know just be at the ready to
go help whoever is in the field maybe
you know 10 or so kilometers or whatever
it might be from the from the main
element anyone ever get contacted yeah
we did on one operation uh
it actually was um
the quick story is that we observed an
arms transfer recall we were enforcing
the date and peace accords and um and
and we saw
russian forces handing weapons to
uh
serbians which is
not the dayton peach peace accords and
this is early early in the day of no
light uh you know
no light cameras and
near real time satcom sending it back so
we got pictures
and uh
documented the whole thing
and then uh we weren't set up to do any
sort of offensive operations you know we
had a whatever 80 pound packs for three
days and you know as many ham sandwiches
as you could stuff in your backpack but
the uh the um there was a nearby army
special forces house that that could get
out get out and get underway we called
them in they went and looked through the
the the building where the transfer had
happened and i i mean i just assumed
that that meant we would be our mission
would be over
you know the age-old
saying if you assume if you think you've
been compromised assume you have and if
you have x-fill and this was a
leadership thing i got put against the
army major at the time who was in charge
of the the sock c the special operations
command and control element
said charlie mike uh continue mission
and i was and i remember over computer
kind of getting in a little bit of an
argument with him and saying hey here's
what we do in the seals this means we're
over ultimately talked about it with a
couple of us the six of us that were in
the field said hey boys what do we think
here liz this is we have time to talk
this through and and everybody said you
know what it's let's let's let's just
continue mission let's not make this an
issue we don't feel that threatened so
someone just catch everyone up here so
you're in the field you see this weapons
transfer and you do this you you tell
the story in the book with with great
detail and it's an awesome story
but
you're you're in the field you're doing
a reconnaissance
you see this weapons transfer take place
and it's illegal and it shouldn't be
happening and you actually get
photographs of it and you push those up
over satcom which but this is not like
the movies this is this is a legit
effort to get that done and very cool
that you guys were able to pull that off
you get photographs of this weapons
transfer taking place
and then you send that up the chain of
command and what the chain of command
does is pushes a special forces group
out to go inspect the area
which
clearly anyone with
any sort of tactical sense is going to
go oh we just did a weapons transfer and
now the u.s military's there there's
someone watching
and so your thought is okay once the
green berets go and inspect that site we
need to get the hell out of here well
you get told by the chain of command no
you're not leaving you're going to stay
eyes on and this is where you have the
discussion hold on a second what do you
mean stay here
and so that's where you're at so what's
the decision
so we we stayed and then not a few hours
later we were being you know actively
hunted by we counted 19 armed
individuals looking through this tree
line and trying to figure out where we
were
and you know we were set up with two ops
uh observation posts and then one cp
command post so so two six people in the
field two two and two i was in the
command post with my my radium and and i
did not have eyes on i was back a bit
and then there's uh in one of the
command in one of the observation posts
uh
chad wilkinson who um you know rest in
peace hero
uh you had sarah wilkinson another
amazing american hero on your your show
recently uh just you know one of my
lifelong friends and um
basically radioed back to me and said
hey boss we got to make a decision here
we're get we're there's somebody coming
down the tree line and we either need to
you know take them out or or fall back
and i just said listen chad here's the
deal if you take him out just know that
we're gonna have you already know this
we'll have 18 other people hunting us
even more actively but do whatever you
think is right and i'm behind you
and um and he ultimately with one other
guy that he was with pulled back took
eyes off
didn't shoot and to this day i think
that was one of the greatest decisions
ever because we the six of us got back
together and then we just worked our way
out of a really tricky problem i
remember two or three times
having my weapon in hand coming off safe
finger on the trigger with a like an
albanian
uh you know
insurgent if you will walking feet from
me and saying okay please don't let me
have to shoot this guy because it'll be
a bad day yeah it's cool and we made it
out we ultimately made it out
yeah um and this is like i said and it's
hard for people to really it might be
hard for people to comprehend this this
is pre-911
so you're out there doing real
operations before the war kicks off and
getting yourself into leadership
situations and
um
learning a lot and really
being pretty being pretty lucky in that
situation for sure big time
um
so you get done with that deployment and
then what do you do next well i screen
to go to seal team six and as you know
they take only a handful of officers
every year and i screened positive i
needed to come back from deployment just
a couple of weeks early to go to what
they call green team
and my commanding officer said mike you
can't come home early you can apply
again next year and i just remember
being so disappointed
and uh and i came home and i was like
you know what forget this i'm i just
don't see a future in the seals for me
after this and
and that's right around that was
literally the time when we started
deploying again as two platoons going
overseas and they said mike i got a
different job for you stay here at seal
teammate be in charge of two seal
platoons and i had a hard decision to
make because i i just wanted to go to to
development group and and and be the
best of the best and in those days like
that's where you went if you really
wanted to you know be in the mix
the regular teams uh weren't in the mix
nearly as much and i just
ultimately you know like many times in
life you don't don't overreact and and
stay calm and think about what's the
best thing and
and uh to this day i'm i'm i look back
at that decision as as
my as as incredibly fortuitous because
my life wouldn't have panned out the way
it did and so you know
9 11 happened and all of us in the teams
had way more work than we ever would
have wanted and so
life works out you don't always think it
does in the moment when you get really
uh frustrated with a decision that's not
breaking your way but when you zoom out
over time things usually work out
where were you when september 11th
happened
i was on the pull-up bars at steel team
eight
so
a handful of us just doing a command pt
and just
really just never forget the moment
so at this point were you a task unit
commander uh yeah i was in charge of two
seal platoons and we were in the in our
work up we weren't close to being
deployed overseas but like everything we
were scrambling and i actually remember
that there were questions like who knows
how to operate stinger missiles this is
when there are planes in the sky nobody
knew what was going on and and we were
getting ready to go uh you know
arm
basically protect
the ships and just homeland defense if
you will if that's what it took so
we ended up not doing any of that but uh
just watching on tv just like everybody
else but but as you know that
that infamous day really changed all of
our future and then where'd you go on
deployment when you so now did you take
that task unit on deployment we we did
and um
and we went over to
germany in europe at the european
command and we were
we were
really
ready to go and didn't get put into the
mix early on so it was again a little
bit disappointing and i said to myself
what in the world i'm sitting here as a
a task unit commander
ready to serve the nation and we have
forces at the ready but but uh we're in
the wrong theater and uh there was talk
about every day there was talk about
pulling us from europe over uconn over
to centcom to help out it didn't happen
and again i said all right you know what
if this is the way that things are gonna
break i applied for the the paul mill
fellowship the political military
fellowship no seal had ever been picked
for two years of fully funded grad
school and i said all right i'm at the
stage of life where i need to to think
about other things and i thought let me
just put my name in the hat here and i
was the lucky squirrel that was picked
and i i got two years of fully funded
grad school and then went to um to grad
school in cambridge mass for for two
years from 03 to 05. so the whole early
phase of the war
i was largely an observer
when you there's a
i again i
asked often about this especially from
young seal leaders right now
because
you know every seal joins the well you
hope that every seal joins the teams
because they want to go to war and then
there's no wars going on
how was it so you're in a task unit
you've got a fully capable task unit
you've september 11th has happened when
when is this deployment to you come
um is it like 2001.
so that would have been yeah 01. it was
one yeah so you go on deployment 0102
and you've got a bunch of hungry
frogmen
and they're sitting around in europe
that's exactly right
what's the uh what what did you do to
try and keep your your forces focused on
the mission at hand pull-ups
[Laughter]
yeah that's a rough one yeah it was a
rough one it sure was i've had i've told
many uh young seals that i was in the
seal teams for 13 years before i ever
shot my weapon at the enemy
and
you don't know and all you can do is
keep going keep doing workups and keep
going on deployment keep training that's
the best thing you can do is keep doing
workups keep going on deployment keep
trying to get better and
they're the nation's gonna call at some
point
totally agree
um
so you are you thinking maybe once you
get done with that deployment it sounds
like you're also the new young frogman
that's pretty pissed off at not going to
war uh so you apply to go to school you
go up
you get are you thinking you're going to
get out after that or well no you you
you you incur a three-year obligation so
at that point i had i don't know 12 or
so years in but i was like i i wanted to
finish 20 years with a master's degree
and so you know the kennedy school of
government was a really good path you
know being the first seal
for this program i thought great i
applied at harvard business school and
then the detailer was like way that's a
little too far off the reservation you
can do a masters in public policy uh at
the kennedy school and i applied there
and and got in so that was um and that
took me from 03 to 05 and then as you
know a date burn in every seals head is
june 28 2005 i had orders to seal team
10. all the guys on the other helicopter
were all teammates from seal teammate
and uh and i went overseas right away
and took over for for eric christensen
god rest him and uh and basically took
over for the
guys who were in who weren't shot down
on june 28 2005. oh
man so
so that so so
that shot that sh that that [__]
happened oh no not a better way to say
it
and you are the guy that goes
then to team 10 and you go on deployment
and you take over
for christensen yep i'd already been a
task unit commander and i was like so
privileged to be able to do it again i
you know i felt like my calling was to
help all the guys who were um
who lived through that who really had a
heart a really hard day
you write in the book about some of the
some of the
things that you implemented
to try and help guys out from uh
i guess a psychological and spiritual
perspective
talk us a little talk us through that a
little bit not only um what you did but
also what made you what gave you the
awareness you know this is pretty early
on
in the war and you seem to be
so you seem to somehow be instinctively
or intuitively know that guys are going
to need some help
yeah i think look i i i like to say in
life i just have varying levels of
ignorance on everything and some things
i'm a little less ignorant on but this
was definitely one of them i i
in talking to the guys i realized that
this isn't a problem we're going to
solve alone kind of your voice example
for the the squeaky voice guy earlier
you know and so
know what you're good at know what
you're not good at and know how to bring
in teammates that that are are better at
things than you and and and so we i
asked to have a psychologist and a
chaplain come out
and took everybody in the platoon aside
and i said listen i've had one-on-one
conversations with every single one of
you you are all struggling with things
in different different things and in
different ways i will never talk about
any of our conversations with anybody
else it's not pub it's not for public
knowledge
but but here's the deal
i i want every single one of you to
spend at least five minutes with the
chaplain in five minutes with the psych
it's it was very counter cultural at the
time at the time you know all we did
was grow up showing either strength or
perceived strength and and this was kind
of like weakness and it
could be perceived as weakness clearly
not but um but in those days could be
perceived as weakness and you know we we
had the you know the guys who would you
know beat their chest and say no effing
way am i talking to the chaplain and
blah blah blah and i was just like okay
the way to get through this is make
everybody do it and there'll be no
stigma for who did and who didn't talk
and
and um
and uh there wasn't a single person who
didn't talk less than several hours to
each of the psych and the chaplain we
had to extend them there for a couple
weeks and and really i think set the
foundation for a couple things number
one is for each of those guys in their
own lives as they dealt with you know
the post-traumatic stress of of doing
the body recoveries from the downed
helicopter and putting their buddies in
bags and bringing them home uh which
which clearly isn't easy and just the
extreme loss of of teammates and such it
was the first real mass casualty that
the seals had in uh in the modern era
and so
i just felt like it was a no-brainer to
me to to bring in to bring in help and
then i ultimately as i returned from
that deployment made a real push to get
a psychologist on the staff and to begin
the era
of of really saying asking for help is a
sign of strength not weakness
yeah you definitely get some credit for
some foresight there because
um yeah that's that that culture that we
have in seal teams of like just suck it
up um just deal with it and that's just
the way it's going to be
um for you to sort of see beyond that
that's definitely um
that's an admirable move right there
we're we're just here to help each other
um
so you guys get done with that
deployment
and come home and and now
what do you do now now are you the ops
officer at team 10 or excel this is the
arrow where the ops officer at a team
became an o4 so i had already been an
ops officer 103 i became the ops officer
as an 04 so this is why my career has
been it was awesome i just spent sealed
teams my whole life i never did a boat
unit tour i never did an stv tour i just
was in this perfect storm of always seal
team seal team seal team so now i'm an
ops officer again i already know how to
do the job pretty decently
we
and that's really you know o5
all the way through late 07
which included a six-month deployment as
as the deputy commander for sotofwest
and onbar which you know very well i was
i think one i was like a couple months
after you is when i got there
and um
and so just
with you know some augmentations i uh
got to get out to theater a couple times
during the workup for a month we were
really aggressively augmenting guys
forward as you you recall so
so you guys roll out to iraq and what
2007 you take your the team is going on
deployment yeah it was um spring of 07.
and this is this is when jason redmond's
out with you guys yeah redmond is when
he got he got wounded and the other guys
with him got wounded um what was that
deployment like from your perspective
dude that's where all my like
it was
uh night after night of stopping bad
thing people from doing bad things to
good people you know we were literally
like vampire hours one cycle of darkness
operations you know as soon as the the
the sun goes down think about you know
you vary your operation do you leave the
fob at 10 30 p.m or 11 45 p.m you know
it's like and and you remember these
days really well but just one cycle of
darkness you get back before sunrise
you know you you lay down around six in
the morning and you get back up at 10
a.m and you rinse and repeat it was a
really high up tempo and in soda west we
had about i want to say about 15 or
maybe 18 kind of out stations throughout
the anbar province and so there was
always something going on somewhere
and uh i'll say i was i was really
fortunate team 10 and team seven came
together we we um so the ceo of team
seven was the ceo of the
the von barr and i was the deputy
commander
and you know really privileged just a
quick aside i one of my
one of my favorite most memorable
memorable buds instructors mark crampton
just beat the hell out of us and
and and used to do berm sprints and and
just would get out there and lead from
the front and i was just always so
impressed with this man back in 93 when
i went through training on this
deployment in 2007 mark's the command
master chief for seal team seven in one
of my some of my greatest days where
mark and i strap hanging and going out
on operations and literally the two of
us you know two guys who didn't have to
go on the operations going out every
third night and it was just super
meaningful for me and that's why you
know as i visited coronado yesterday
so one of the
the way i started my workout was going
to the very berm where
where mark used to make us
do those berm sprints and i just had
some quiet time all by myself and just
you know spoke in my head to mark and
and uh you know just paid a huge tribute
to him just yesterday and made myself
super effing miserable and um
and uh you know it's it's it's this is
this is the weight that we all carry you
know so for those who don't mark died by
suicide about three weeks ago just
before easter this couple weeks ago yeah
um
a guy that he
i never saw him without a smile on his
face in my whole career never saw him
without a smile on his face with a great
attitude looking to help everybody just
just
just pure positivity and um
just sh
shocking i i don't know how to explain
it
were you guys um were you guys working
with iraqis was every element out there
working with iraqis we were but you know
as well as i do it a lot of it was
window dressing
you know hey guys we got to start
building these guys up we got to take
you know six or 12 iraqis with us on the
mission and it was early in the days of
actually
you know really committing to trying to
build the iraqi army
we tried we tried to build the iraqi
army and
we
would take them out and it was
definitely the one of the biggest
challenges was trying to work with the
iraqi army especially at that time and
that's why it was very
it was very rewarding when they pushed
into missoula later in 2000 you know
17 18 19 and the iraqis did a lot of the
fighting and they made incredible
sacrifices which
you know at the time when when i was
there in 2006
you you wouldn't anticipate them
stepping up many of them
stepping up at all you know there's if
there was a few brave iraqi soldiers for
sure but a lot of them you would think
well they're not going to be able to
ever do this for themselves
yeah well for us i mean so i got spring
that deployment started i think was
march of 07 and i recall the peak of the
insurgency by using the metric of
attacks on americans which we know is a
flawed metric when you have more
americans there are more attacks on
americans but the um
but the
uh
there were the way to
to kind of quantify it is my first 30
days in theater in fallujah we lost 35
marines from the greater fallujah area
and um and so it was just night after
night we didn't we were in the real
early innings of of being able to
actually confidently take
a lot of iraqis out on operations and
let them take the risk for their own
nation
what'd you bring back from that
deployment for lessons learned
wow that's a great question i think the
the main thing is sustained operations
the importance of um
of efficiency and making sure that that
um
that you don't have seals or special
forces um doing things that don't take
seals to do you know when i grew up
there was a little bit of an attitude in
in coming out of buds that's like i'm a
seal you're not
you know there's there's the seals and
there's the non-seals at the team and i
think the you i know you live this way
also the faster you learn
that an integrated team
is what it needs what it takes to be
successful the faster your trajectories
to success these are things that weren't
learned quite as quickly in the early
days but in that deployment all of the
younger guys that that were able to hand
off you know the iraqis the the the
insurgents that they
took off a target hand them to somebody
else to interrogate them and you know
there's a lot of people that can ask
questions and interrogate you don't have
to be a sealed to have that skill or
intelligence analysts or whatever the
case may be and so i think we got really
good at saying what's the part of the
job that just takes a seal to do what's
that comparative advantage and then how
do you hire
people for everything else yeah yeah
even i i tell this to leaders all the
time do
you should be doing things that only you
can do
and if someone else can do it you're in
a leadership position let someone else
do it and if there's no one else can do
it cool then that's an indication that
maybe you should start training someone
to do that other thing that you only at
this time can do because as long as
you're the only person that can do a job
guess what you're gonna be doing that
job
yeah and that's that should be your goal
not to be doing the same thing forever
and if you're doing that job that means
you're looking down and instead of being
able to look up and out
and see what the next horizon's going to
be see what the next market's going to
be see where we can maneuver to those
are all things we need to look at
um
you get done with that deployment and
this is this when you went to the white
house yeah i finished three years
basically of running pretty hard as the
xo uh so so the the the ops officer and
then fleet it up as the xo at seal team
10. did you deploy again with the 17 as
the xl i did and then where'd you go on
that oh sorry that was the iraq
deployment okay god that was that was a
deployment
so i did two deployments one is like the
right out of grad school got it and then
the the exo seal team uh iraq deployment
um i so come back and for for everybody
listening we're really good about
succession planning in the seals you
know once you're in the seat a seat for
two or three years you're you're
thinking how you have to get out of your
seat and make room for the next guy
and
we do these diversity tours i was
fortunate my first diversity tour was
you know graduate school for two years
in cambridge mass and it was time for me
to get out of my chair as the exo seal
team 10 and i applied for the white
house fellowship it's a non-military
program it is
a great
leadership public service program i
threw you know i say throw my name in
the hat it's quite an extensive
application process and um ultimately
was picked the there are thousands of
applicants the nation picks 14 to be
white house fellows every year and i got
placed as the director for defense
policy and strategy for bush so
literally report to the national
security adviser who reports to the
president like day seven i'm running my
first meetings in the white house
situation room it like it was a lot of
steep learning uh walking around
pretending like you know how to your way
around washington dc you know i'm like
you know dumb team guy all of a sudden
thrown in the policy world
but uh you got speaking of getting this
job and the selection process you got a
cool thing in here that that talks about
that a little bit uh going back to the
book my interviewer sat me down and
asked a bunch of questions a bunch of
introductory questions then stared at me
with intensity and said mike what do you
know about the start treaty
i took a breath looked at him and said
with deadpan seriousness i know how to
spell it
honestly i didn't know anything about
our nation's nuclear treaties not a bit
but what i did know and i told them this
too was how to get the right people into
a room and how to run the decision
making process
i knew how to figure out what motivated
people how to get them to generate ideas
how to cooperate and ultimately how to
leave the room with the best possible
outcome
i wasn't afraid to admit that i didn't
know a thing about nuclear policy and i
think that's what got me the job being
humble enough to admit that being humble
enough to admit what you don't know but
still confident enough to explain where
you can add value is a balance that's
often hard to strike but you need to
recognize that it's a strength not a
weakness to know what's beyond your
knowledge or understanding at any point
in time instead of pretending otherwise
i walk into any room and always assume
that people in it are smarter than i am
faster than i am and more agile than i
am that way i can never be wrong i never
assume i have the idea i have an idea
maybe it's the best one or maybe it's
not but honestly it shouldn't even
matter because our job in any room is to
find the best answer for the problem
we're working on no matter whose answer
it is
we have to listen to each other and
really hear each other and the best way
to do that is to walk into the room
knowing there's no doubt that everyone
in there has something useful to say
so that's how you ended up with that job
not by being this not by being the
smartest guy about nuclear treaties but
by saying hey look i don't know
everything about that but i can help
make a decision
it's it's exactly what you talk about in
extreme ownership it's it's the exact
same way we've grown up in the seals and
and just espousing that for sure
so you're working at the at the white
house so what's this job what's the
first job that you get
when you get there as a white house
fellow what's the first job well the
white house fellowship is has kind of
like three legs of the stool as an
active white house fellow
you're you're wearing a suit to work
every day it's not a it's not a uniform
job and so
the program has
places you in a full-time job throughout
the year and and some people opt into a
job that's a little bit more
a little bit more
fellowy meaning you don't have really
that many obligations you're there to
learn you just get to observe and i'm
like you know i want to really get in
the mix you know so i had opportunities
at the department of commerce and i had
opportunities at national security
council and so i thought
do i go deeper in something i know
national security do i go to commerce
and learn something new and ultimately
you can't pass up the
the uh the role where you're going to be
in the west wing and be uh
just in the mix with the nation's
hardest problems and so
that um
so so with that the fellows also get
together though a couple times a week
and you listen to
you know cabinet secretaries the vice
president the the president and and and
so on and just ask them questions and
you learn it's all off the record and 14
fellows plus the president or 14 fellows
plus the vice president and
it's just a tremendous program but
you're really
if you pick a job that that is a real
a job with real responsibilities
it's a hard year
when you
see the news now
and i mean i guess it's just like seeing
like a movie about like a military movie
how you and i will watch a military
movie and it's like oh that would never
happen oh that's always
how is it for you now you look you look
at what's happening in the white house
and you know all these inner workings of
what's going on behind the scenes
what is it what give us a little glimpse
of what it's like going on behind the
scenes yeah you know i think the real
thing that is not sexy is process but
process is what accelerates outcomes and
so when you think about it there's 17
acres of the white house but but there
are
bajillions of different decisions that
need to be made and so not everybody can
bring their decision to the top of the
house and so at my level i ran a a
certain
meeting in the in this in the white
house situation room and it's it's
simple it's a binary outcome you know
with it's either
we agree
in which case national policy is made or
if not then we
uh we suss out what is what are the
different stakeholders think what does
the department of state or department of
defense or energy or the intel community
think and
and why can't we compromise and so by
definition only the harder issues are
bubbling up to then a deputies committee
meeting where the number two
runs it again binary outcome at a
deputies committee meeting they either
agree and make policy or not and then it
becomes a principles committee meeting
where you have the national security
advisor chairing it and you've got the
sec death the sex state all the the
number ones of all the departments and
agencies around the table again binary
outcome agree or not if agree great
policy made if not that's going to the
president and so by definition you've
created a system where you get volume
and flow and but only but only the
hardest things are making it to the top
sometimes that runs well sometimes that
doesn't run well and so as i sit back
you know
i think about you know how are things
working are they working like they can
or should as soon as decisions get made
outside of that process
you you you you actually diminish
the um probability of the best possible
decision getting made because you know
as well as i do
if not everybody's at the table and you
make a decision you've kind of alienated
a bunch of stakeholders and you don't
get everybody rowing in the same
direction so that's kind of the lens
that i look at at washington dc and uh
you know
i think sometimes we're we're way more
broken than we we should be but other
times i think you know it's it's
seeing the smartest mind solve some of
the really hardest problems we have we
have a lot to be proud of and we have a
lot to work on in this in this nation
so what which meeting is it that you
would run
you said
out of all these meetings which which
one were you which level of meetings
would would you run so every
administration changes the name a little
bit just because they need to you know
put the their own stamp on on what it's
called but a policy coordinating
committee uh was what what it was called
in the bush administration as an example
a pcc i think it was if i might even be
wrong on that but a three-letter acronym
that was you know something that changes
but um but but but the point is i'd be
at the head of the table and you'd have
basically assistant secretary level
people or you know roughly two three
star-ish generals uh from the from the
department of defense um you know just
whoever the stakeholder was for the
particular issue some people from under
secretary of defense in the policy shop
sitting there and and look i i'm not
trying to glorify myself or be the
president of the fan club i'm a guy who
ran the process but the thing is that's
that's the role if you can run the
process really well
then it makes the nation run well you
know and
uh you know i've been often asked a
little bit of a segue here but you know
hey as we got out of afghanistan what
went wrong the thing that went wrong was
policy process broke down
who are we bringing home we didn't have
a question an answer to that question
and so that caused a lot of chaos and a
little a lot of people rushed to an
airport hoping to get onto a flight
you know so anyways that that's just one
example of the how policy the the the
engine and the machine
should work
how many hours a day are you working in
oh that was long hours that was you know
i'd go i'd get in it you know
not
i always get my workout in in the
morning i honestly got there you know 7
30 7 8 o'clock i'm like that but um but
it was home at ten o'clock on a lot of
nights
and then a lot of times you know paying
attention to the blackberry i'll date
myself oh 708
no nine time frame and um in fact i
remember very well one night at three in
the morning the blackberry just buzzing
non-stop which usually didn't wake me up
but it did this night and that's where
the guy captain richard phillips got
got taken hydrogen was hijacked on the
maersk alabama and then i come i called
a friend of mine chris domencic who was
at uh at
at team six and said hey man a million
layers between you and me but you gotta
go start looking at this right now
and and uh you know hours later i'm in
my suit in the basement of the pentagon
and the nmcc the national military
command center and just trying to work
the problem and and ultimately ran i i
ran that whole thing from
the uh the national security council and
one of the cooler things was
you know running these meetings and you
know president obama would walk in and
there's only only about four five six of
us kind of running this this um
this uh situation and when the whole
thing was done president obama wrote a
really nice note on white house station
or stationary mike great job on the
somalia situation you made a family very
happy at easter barack
jack yeah it's pretty cool
yeah you have a little uh little section
here that i thought was pretty cool
talking about that as this is going down
you get these you get these uh text or
whatever the the blackberry's buzzin you
say i called the pentagon and a one-star
admiral who was on duty told me that his
guidance was not to prepare any options
to deal with the situation
i responded with something i said only
twice in my two years in my position at
the national security council
quote sir please take this as direction
from the white house
end quote
i told him that the department of
defense needed to prepare military
options to rescue the crew and keep the
pirate captors from selling captain
phillips to al-shabaab or another
terrorist organization the only question
i said to the admiral
is how fast can you have options back to
the national security council by the
afternoon my biggest worry had become
real the pirates had left the ship
putting the crew putting the crew out of
danger but they had taken captain
phillips with them and were holding him
hostage on a lifeboat heading toward
shore fortunately by that point the
department of defense had done what it
does best and was giving the national
security council and the president real
options to address a really hard problem
my friend
my friend scott commander of the entire
task force
being deployed for the mission and chris
a leader of the tactical response itself
arrived on scene halfway around the
globe in a matter of hours after the
mission was launched they averted a
crisis on easter sunday as they shot
three pirates with three rounds in the
dark knight while both their ship and
the pirates lifeboat rocked up and down
on the swells of the open ocean
scott chris and their snipers were the
true heroes of that day
it's no different than third phase of
buds do you remember when we were
thinking
we're told
think about what can go wrong on your
mission
think forward what are all the things
that can happen so it's not like i was
anybody special in the white house i was
just doing what i grew up with in the
seal teams it's the same thing you or
any other you know seal leader would
have done which is hey this could
actually go bad and here's how it can go
bad and we're going to prepare for the
worst case not the best case
have you been to the udtco museum in
fort pierce florida not lately but but i
have they have they have the lifeboat
there yeah i don't know if you know that
yeah i i've seen pictures of it but yeah
yeah that's pretty awesome a pretty
awesome uh
group doing pretty awesome stuff there
um
so that's so that's this white house
fellow position and you that's an
interesting going from george w bush to
barack obama um what did you notice
about those two leaders
first of all uh
great governors of people and great
leaders in different ways uh you know
the um
the press has a certain view and a
certain lens on things and having been
on the inside i'll just it's really
obvious statement but just don't believe
everything you see or read so that was
another great set of lessons that would
what came out of that two years in
washington dc for me the white house
fellowship was supposed to only be a
year but after that captain phillips
thing president obama said hey can you
stay my whole administration so i stayed
at state a second year and and continued
uh in in my role but um
you know the
at really at the end of the day it was
about um
about
seeing an administration in year seven
and a half
is a lot different than an
administration in minute one
and so people can think about oh the
right and the left for sure that can
there's there's of course policy
differences not as many in national
security ironically once you get briefed
up and you're really like in the the the
tssci top secret sensitive compartment
information of like what's happening in
the world
politics actually causes the the
opinions to narrow a good bit because
there's only so many solutions to the
national security problems but the um
the thing i would say is um setting
aside right and left issues uh it's
really
uh
an
energy you know you're seeing the third
or fourth person in the role at year
seven and a half of an administration
and you're seeing somebody else on
minute one who's got incredible energy
and they're just happy to be they're
happy to be there they might not know
where the light switches are for the
first few weeks but but it's um but
that's the beauty of the
the permanent staff
that that kind of works as part of the
institution in in dc
and i've always felt
you know people will complain that
nothing ever changes
well there's some positivity to things
being hard to change in our government
would you say that's an accurate
assessment agree 100
like i don't want the government to be
at the whim of whoever's in charge to
just whip it one way or the other no i
think our nation's forefathers made it
easy to kind of bump down the the
highway but not to get off the road
awesome all right so you wrap that up
and and
while you're there is this when you
figure out that you're going to go to
seal team 2 as the ceo it is and you
know i was handling afghanistan policy
as well and scott moore was the detailer
the scot that you just referred to in
the in the um previous passage and he
said hey mike you're gonna you're gonna
take over seal team two can you get
yourself out of the white house like we
can't pull you out like you're the only
one who's gonna have to you know and of
course after two years i was dude i was
ready for my next challenge and um and
ultimately got permission to leave and
and i said i've got a great opportunity
and
i knew i'd be deploying back to
afghanistan because
as you well know the nat the naval
special warfare community doesn't
frequently get
real estate to own and so we had
southeastern afghanistan and and it was
a great opportunity to not just take a
seal team overseas but to integrate
a bunch of you know green berets a bunch
of you know uh you know infantry from
the army and just every single aspect of
of what the
what the nation's department of defense
really is yeah what's that what a huge
what a huge step for
the community you know i was talking to
admiral richards and and those guys that
had this sort of vision that we should
be deploying and that in that
even with the idea that we should be
deploying like that like as a team ceo
deploying overseas like that was those
guys came up with this idea and and
thankfully they came up with it before
september 11th and they kind of it
wasn't there yet i mean what was
remember vision 2000 and all that like
that was them trying to formulate this
idea but yeah this is an example of how
well that actually worked the
opportunities that were there
so so awesome and so exciting as a
commander of a seal team to be able to
bring your whole team overseas to one
to one effort and and to make a
meaningful impact yeah i mean four just
so everybody knows for
pretty much for the entire history of
the seal teams
it was gonna be onesies and twosies a
platoon going here or maybe a couple
platoons going there and
that was what they did in vietnam it was
like one or two platoons at a time
deploying the seal team commander was
back in coronado or back in virginia
beach and they were just kind of
watching and and
then to have this idea that actually a
seal team
the whole team should be able to deploy
and then the team should be able to take
on other assets and utilize those assets
i mean it's
we got to be very thankful for those
senior leaders that came up with that
plan for sure totally agree and i would
say that you were uh you you were
definitely
a benefactor of those things
couldn't be couldn't be more accurate so
so appreciative so you show up at a team
what was your was your attitude coming
back to the team oh fired up man to like
get out of the white house and uh
wearing a suit every day for two years i
was ready for some sand and
surf zone
you show up
and the work up
anything particular that you guys
focused on during the workup well you
know we knew of course knowing it's a
real benefit to also know you're really
preparing for afghanistan and you you
get to not prepare for a bunch of
different things and and so we minimized
i hate to say this but we minimized
diving we had to make hard decisions
like we're not going to be diving in
afghanistan let's not go spend three
weeks diving it just doesn't make sense
and um and yes it kind of moved us away
from our roots a little bit but that was
that was
that's what commanders do is you make
the those types of decisions and so for
me i was really moved when i went
overseas i went to afghanistan to spend
a couple weeks out in theater early on
in command
and you know i was there when um we lost
uh three seals in a helicopter
crash out in zabal province
and of course terrible terrible incident
you know being there
uh really left a serious mark on me i
mean of course you know i've been
exposed to everything already in my
career but when you really feel that you
feel that you are the owner of the risk
of the whole team
it's a different feeling
there's a i used to think when i was
second in charge of a seal team that it
wouldn't really be that different to be
overall in charge i couldn't have been
more wrong
so uh when i when
a senior leadership team
from
from seal team two
did our advanced
reconnaissance if you will
we came home on a medevac where i'll
never forget
uh there was a young man who was
blown up in an ied who was really just
being flown to germany just so he could
pass away in germany next to his wife he
was in a coma
and and i'll never forget like a you
know six or eight hour flight just
spending it next to this whole guy just
with my hand on him talking to him and
just some army trooper who i i don't
even don't even know his name but like
when you're really around that it i got
back to the states and i i i already
worked hard but i worked
like it really stepped up the
like this is real like i will bring all
my guys home and and um and we'll do
everything we can
yeah it's um
those uh we we experienced that going
getting to ramadi like as soon as we get
there there's
there's soldiers and marines getting
killed just about every day and and we
would go to those services whenever we
could but it was out of the gate we were
hitting two three services in a row and
it's a wake-up call to everybody to
to the recognition of
what's going on out in that battlefield
every single day which which you know
you could hear it going on you could see
it going on you could see vehicles you
could see guys getting casual backed out
um we were given blood when he could
whenever we could give blood like just
that um
heavy reality of going into these
scenarios
um
you guys you guys
finish your work up you you go on that
that pre-deployment and now you've got
your platoon your your team over there
your whole team never mind just the
platoons now you got the whole team and
it's not just your team it's you got sf
guys you've got you've got an entire
like force here
it sounds like from the book you you had
a little bit of a rough relationship
with uh with the conventional commander
that was there
initially with the one who was right
next to me in taran coutt this uh guy
just didn't want to get out and put his
force at risk to go do great things
and you know as well as i do you just
you just don't respect people that don't
want to do their job
so uh that being said um you're you're
determined and you're gonna go make
things happen you got some you got your
you got your platoons
your teams
your forces
still out there still getting after it
um
but
you gotta know when it's time to not get
after it
gotta know when it's time to push back
you got a thing here that's a really
good lesson and it's a really good
lesson and you do this in the book you
counter it to the time when the major
told you in kosovo was it kosovo to stay
out in the field
and you go you know what we're just
going to stay out in the field like you
told us you know we'll we'll that that
seems like the right call right now it's
a little bit different here
um going to the book
to ensure civilian casualties were as
limited as possible and that the
innocent afghan civilians wouldn't turn
against our forces the military set up a
policy called boots on the ground battle
damage assessment
this meant that after every bomb we
dropped we were we were required
to physically go to the site to confirm
that no civilians had been killed the
theory a smart theory was that knowing
we would have to acknowledge civilian
casualties would make it less likely
that there would be any civilian
casualties
a talented team of army green berets
within my command had intelligence at
one point that there were approximately
10 taliban members gathered together at
three in the morning in an area no
civilian would ever go and certainly not
at that time
the team used surveillance techniques to
view the site and we knew as a certainty
that there were no civilians there
they asked me for permission to drop a
bomb from an unmanned aircraft and
following the decision-making process
i'd put in place i granted it
they went ahead and eight of the taliban
fighters were killed
an army colonel from the commanding
general staff in afghanistan called and
asked my watch officer for our bda
report
and my watch officer explained that we
didn't have one that it was simply too
much risk for not a good enough reason
the road to the site was too dangerous
to travel and we knew there were no
civilians present and to ask anyone on
my team to go down this isolated path in
the middle of the night was an
unnecessary risk to their lives and one
it made no sense to take
i got on the phone with the colonel and
we went back and forth this is the
policy
but the policy in this case makes no
sense to achieve an already known
outcome i will not take unnecessary risk
that my men will die
there are consequences in the military
for not following the orders of a
superior
truth is the lack of organizational
flexibility is a huge problem for the
military on the ground we were living a
never agile enough kind of life but in
terms of the larger hierarchy the
structure had its weaknesses i could
have been fired and sent home from the
deployment as an insubordinate
but in that moment i couldn't i couldn't
just blindly follow the policy i had to
act consistently with my values and make
a judgment and subsequent decision that
i was going to be able to live with if
the worst happened
the colonel said that since i wouldn't
comply he was going to report my
non-compliance to his boss the
commanding general in afghanistan and
that he would ask his peer in charge of
our afghan partner force to order his
men to unilaterally inspect the site
instead
i urged him not to do that but that
decision was out of my hands
12 afghan soldiers drove down that
isolated road in three vehicles to make
their assessment of the bomb site
the first two trucks hit an ied and
three of the eight people in those two
vehicles were killed with others
seriously wounded
soon after i flew by helicopter to the
out station where the green beret team
was stationed sat with them and told
them how incredibly proud i was of their
amazing bravery the remarkable work they
did night after dangerous night it was
one of the more emotional moments in my
life
as we started our meeting silence fell
over the room and one of the guys on the
team opened by looking me square in the
eyes and quietly but resolutely thanking
me
he knew that the easier decision would
have been caving to the pressure from
above and deviating from my beliefs
and we all knew that would have meant
some of the men in this room would have
died
the green beret had no idea that his
words made my throat almost closed as i
choked up and how hard i had to fight
off tears
i was simply overwhelmed by the real
life impact by the reality of the
situation the overwhelming magnitude of
these kind of decisions made under the
pressure of intense nightly combat take
a toll on people that's difficult to
understand for those who haven't
experienced it now with the benefit of
several years of hindsight and the time
to fully reflect on those past events i
have an even even greater belief in the
importance of process your own process
and of values-based decision-making
process can
no exaggeration
save people's lives
yeah um
a point i like to bring up in situations
like this is if you're in a leadership
position and someone below you in the
chain of command is
refusing to do something or pushing back
that hard
you should probably listen to them
and this is a situation i mean when as i
was reading this
as soon as i saw you know it go to oh
he's going to order someone else to do i
just was i already knew the outcome
because i know you're not pushing back
for no reason you're pushing back for
good reason
uh
it might be hard for people to
understand the kind of pressure that
you're under to kind of concede and and
just go with uh what you're being told
to do
there's times in life you got to just
put it on the table and say be ready for
the outcome be ready to be fired
you always hear pick your battles
this was unquestionably one of them and
this is why you are in command and this
is why
this is
everything that you've trained to do at
that point in life is for that it's for
a moment like that
it's to have confidence in yourself that
you're that you're right
and to not take that unnecessary risk i
still get you know emotional as you were
reading it i haven't you know
i you know i sit back and i can
very tactilely
feel sitting in that room
in the silence and me
looking at all these guys and and really
knowing that that me having the backbone
saved you know several of their lives
and not not being able to look at which
guy wasn't there or which guy you know
it would have been
but it's just the weight of combat gets
really hard over time and um
and there's certain moments like that
where you just say to yourself this [__]
is real
how long was this deployment that was 10
months
that's a long deployment for seals yeah
it is what was there was was were we
correcting a deployment cycle or
something like that was it one of those
things what happened we were just trying
to stretch our forces more get more out
of the forces we had so lengthen it out
a bit
and um and then you could put more
people on the battlefield and and
that it was not more complicated than
that
sometimes nsw's had to kind of make
adjustments and extend someone and cut
someone else short uh but it wasn't that
huh we were just trying to no it was it
was uh aligned with the
uh you know they were aligned with the
command leadership structure for the
joint special operation joint special
operations task force throughout
afghanistan there were you know five
different regions if you will so i was
southeast but there was also you know
obviously south and west and it did and
and that was the cycle that the that the
special operations community was on and
so
if the seals wanted to you know play the
game and have the the battle space you
just had to
acquiesce and do the 10 months you can't
get off cycle with the rest of the
rest of the force but yeah decisions
like that very
um frequently in
literally life and death
what was your
kind of battle rhythm your
your personal battle rhythm during that
deployment like
what time are you going to sleep what
time are you waking up is there any
rhythm jocko i had no rhythm you know i
had a red light in my ceiling that was
anytime there was it was a tick troops
in contact you know my my bedroom was
about a 30-yard sprint down this like
you know plywood palace kind of hallway
to get to the
the
the um the operation center the the
antithesis of the the talk in a rucksack
that you talked about at the beginning
you know we we had the we had the plasma
tvs and the terrain mapping and the
unmanned aerial vehicle feeds and
everything and and you know you you
would just get the the calls that you
know you the you'd hear the the crazy
machine gun fire coming in over the over
the satellite radio and you'd hear one
of your your key leaders whose voices
you know immediately even though they're
not saying their name on the on the on
the satcom radio and they're just calmly
saying what they need it's a i need a
500 pound jdam dropped like yesterday on
this particular location and
and uh and i was the one to make the
decisions on when we dropped bombs and
when we didn't and what operations we
went on and what we didn't and so
because i had i don't know it was
roughly 25 different out stations
throughout the southeast and sometimes
literally i think that uh five six seven
different elements in a tick at a time
i was
i was just i was just on
did you were you the approval for yeah i
was the approval for error yep
yeah so you're busy yeah it was i mean
we
i don't know i don't think i've ever
said this number publicly but it's it's
not you know a secret but we had uh over
1100 air-to-ground drops over 10 months
and i'm proud to say we didn't harm
anybody we shouldn't harm there were
times that we that we said no it wasn't
a lot but
but but you know the mostly the
leadership in the field knew when not to
ask for something but occasionally there
were times it came up when i said no and
i just wasn't comfortable with something
and
so the
the other thing that's interesting when
you ask about the battle rhythm though
is that it was also important to me to
go out on some of the operations with
the guys
and i didn't go out quite as frequently
as i did in iraq but i still got out
maybe once a week or something like that
and it i didn't do that in the beginning
of the deployment because i wanted the
the staff to kind of see the ju the
judgment the decision-making etc but i
had an incredible exo rocky russell and
who i had is
supreme confidence in so i i'd go out on
an operation and be with the
the the afghan commandos in a sealed
platoon for i don't know a day day and a
half two days at times and that's a
that's a tough decision also because as
soon as you swing and go on one
operation with one unit dude you don't
know what's happening with the other 24.
so that takes an element of like
confidence and trust but of course as
you know it makes you a better leader
because it helps you understand and
maintain perspective and frankly just to
share the same risk as the guys you know
and and as a whatever i'm 51 now as a 41
ish year old seal team commander
you know that deployment we got shot at
and rocketed and
the the uh i
i cut one of my guys legs off on that
deployment and um
just what happened
um
there was somebody in an ied who who was
um blown up and we had a mass casualty
situation and so you know
it was it was a we had you know doctors
but they were busy and you know i was
kind of under it wasn't like i did it on
my own the doctor kind of said hey okay
do this do this do this and cut this and
you know go and and because it was a it
was an all hands on deck kind of
thing in the
in our um in our um in our headquarters
at the
it was kind of like the mash unit if you
will you know
oh so you had you had casualties come in
to your location yep
and it was a mass casualty yeah it was
yeah and so you were there freaking they
were like scrubbed up getting it getting
it on i don't even think we scrubbed it
i mean we we you know we we did
i don't remember perfectly but i just
remember we didn't um i i met this guy
at the helicopter who had three
tourniquets on and one of them was um
had come loose and he had arterial
bleeding coming from from the middle of
his leg that was missing and i had to
you know reach in and hold pressure on
arterial bleeder and take them from the
helicopter and get them all the way into
the get them all the way into the
medical unit and there was another guy
who was i mean blown up beyond
recognition but i mean i knew who it was
of course but i mean it was just it was
really really bad and um
and uh and then it was just there were
only a handful of seals in the in the
the uh the headquarters at the moment
and
you know
the the the tick was gone and so it was
that was taken care of and so it was
just all hands on deck and and dealing
with the medical situation and that was
one night but there were several nights
where we had um overwhelming number of
of of people who were shot up or blown
up that we were taken care of
but somehow
from your seal team from seal team two
you guys made it through that deployment
without losing anyone no one was killed
in action yeah
any other any other thing to wrap up on
that deployment
um i i think it's really the main it
really is
the inexplicable
pace and um
and uh dedication that our entire entire
department of defense has
is is really remarkable you know it's
it's uh you just get humbled every day
to see how hard people work in the
austere conditions and you know
both seals and green berets and and
non-seals and non-green berets out in
these hinterlands literally just not
showering
for months on end only eating the food
that helicopters drop into them and just
really putting
country and others before self i i just
was constantly humbled to um
to to be part of an organization with
such great great americans
so
you get home from that deployment
and um
i'm gonna go to the book here
i had been home from afghanistan just
for just a few weeks when i found out
that my replacement
as commander of the special operations
task force
who had taken over my team
finished when my team finished this
deployment had decided to take his own
life shooting himself with his pistol in
his room
in the bed i had slept in for the
previous 10 months
i was shocked and devastated
he and i were good friends former
roommates bud's classmates 20 years
earlier we had come up the ranks
together
before we each got married and started
our families we shared a house in
virginia beach for three years
we were inseparable in those days
we had bonded over our mutual
frustration at the pull-up bar during
buds training one saturday morning after
we both failed the day
before to come anywhere close to
matching the 15 to 20 pull-ups our
fellow trainees were able to do we
decided to go find a pull-up bar to
practice on far away from the buds
compound where no one would stumble upon
us
despite a full night's sleep we were
still struggling as we fought as we each
fought through our fourth pull-up i can
still see his face and hear the chuckle
in his voice as he turned to me and said
world's finest right here
he was loyal genuine a man who could
find humor in absolutely anything
another time in training we were so cold
on a boat ride back to the compound
after an icy swim that we found
ourselves fighting over where to place
one rubber fin that was shielding very
small parts of us from the 40 knot winds
there we were
two grown adults seal trainees fighting
over a tiny rubber fin to help make us a
tiny bit warmer and we and just a little
drop less miserable we stopped for a
moment and realized what we were
fighting over and we both just broke out
in hysterical laughter
it seemed like we were always laughing
back then
when i was deployed he would check in on
my family and when he was deployed i
would check in on his
i would say that i trusted him with my
life except that it was so much more
than that as seals we have no choice but
to trust everyone on our team with our
life every minute of every day on the
battlefield
but when you bond with someone
it's not so much about trusting them
with your life it's about wanting them
to be there in the trenches with you
feeling better because you know they're
right alongside you
he was so much more than a fellow seal
he was a friend a teammate a brother a
shining example
of the bravery a human being can exhibit
man
um
you know
you you talk about
um
the pressure and the pace and the and
the
battle rhythm or lack of rhythm
and the lives at stake
and it's it's it's hard to describe what
that feels like
and it's hard to it's hard to
it's hard to describe what it feels like
i guess is all i can say um
but man this was this was just a
travesty and a shock
to have the the commander on the ground
who'd just taken your place someone you
grew up with in the team somebody i was
at team two with i mean just freaking
good good mug
um
it's it's so hard to understand
yeah this one hurt
they all hurt
some of them hit closer to home than
others you know as i know you've
experienced too and
you know this is
this is the
thing i was talking about and
not
describing well enough before but it's
the um
it's the weight that people carry it's
the it's the
um not
not always knowing the weight that
people carry
and
yeah this that was a tough one for me
you talk a little bit in the book
you know i mean obviously we all have
the we all go through the you know what
could i have done differently maybe i
could have said this or seen that or
done this or done that
is there anything as you look back
is there any pattern did you have any
indication i mean you did a turnover you
know i i was looking um i was looking at
there's a there's an article in the new
york times about this and there's a
there's a there's a situation that you
describe in the book where
i guess the local afghans had gifted you
some kind of a you know ceremonial head
garment of some kind and he was with you
and they kind of ceremonially gave him
as well the same thing and
and it's it's it's i don't know if
you've seen this i'm sure you have but
there's so you write about that in the
book and there's a picture in in the new
york times of you in that there's the
picture of when that happened and for me
it was very tough to look at because i
read it and i kind of imagined it
and
you know then then i then i go on the
new york times i'm reading this article
and i think oh there's the picture
there's exactly what mike was talking
about um
is there anything that you look at that
you think
we need to do a better job of looking
out out for
yeah well i mean let's start that with
me right i think that you know
we've grown up saying
look we can always go blame the world at
everything but
guys like you and me grow up starting
with ourselves and say what could i have
done better and so when i look back at
this particular situation
i recall very vividly on a friday
afternoon two o'clock in the afternoon
or so at a team picking up the red line
and trying to to dial him and just check
on him and see how he's doing
and there was a new policy where you
needed a four-digit pin or something
like that and i was like oh the guys
have already gone home i'm not going to
bug them on a friday afternoon and make
them make my phone work i'll just call
call overseas on monday well that
saturday is when when he took his own
life and i i sometimes look back and say
you know did i did i do enough and i i
certainly wrestle with that and
and it leads me
to a lesson that i talk about which is
not seeing intrusive as a bad thing you
know it's it's a good thing to be
intrusive in people's lives and to ask
the question of like hey really how are
you really doing
have you ever considered harm to self is
a hard question to ask
and it's a little bit embarrassing
sometimes to ask it
but i'll take 99 embarrassings for the
one yes
i miss that here and i won't miss that
again and since then since that happened
i've
had plenty of yeses where i've been able
to to step in and help
um i certainly wish i could have helped
more
in in the past
when you guys were doing a turnover the
turnover i mean just to just so everyone
understands this is like
dude it's the commander or the team it's
the commander of team but also the
turnover this is
for lack of a better word this is like
the most intimate
intellectual exchange you're gonna have
with another human being in your life
hey i've been on the ground
i've been
fighting these troops
we've been at war
i'm gonna give you everything i can to
help you do the job
uh i mean this is as close as you're
gonna intellectually transfer
information between two people and then
plus on top of that you guys are
brothers from buds
and i mean as you're doing this is it is
there any there's nothing there's no you
know jocko i've never said this publicly
the there's just one shred of little
thing when i play back in my mind you
know we didn't lose any americans and in
my last
uh you know
session with the leadership
i celebrated that
but the incoming team was also there
and and my friend you know pulled me
aside afterwards and said hey that was
you know really rough for us to set the
bar to expect that we're not going to
lose anybody
and um
and it turns out that that
the leader from the east coast seal
teams had also
pulled my friend aside and said hey
listen just do the same thing mike did
just bring everybody home
and and he had lost four guys in his
first month and so i think that pressure
of losing people
um in in you know it's it's it just it
didn't it didn't add up um so i don't
say that's the cause
but it's certainly unquestionably a
contributor
oh man
yeah it's um
i i actually remember turning over with
the guys that took over for us and
ramadi and i i told them well because i
had lost guys and i'm like it was a i
remember thinking myself am i gonna say
this yes i am
you guys are gonna take casualties
like you there's a hundred percent
chance you're gonna take casualties
there's a hundred percent certainty that
you're gonna take casualties
and
i mean i've talked to guys since then
that were
in that
group that task unit that relieved us
and they they were like that was the
wake up call for them was holy [__] like
we got our we got the seal team
commander of the task unit telling us we
are 100 certain gonna take casualties um
yeah but all you can do is look at wake
up calls as fuel for improvement in the
future yeah right and that's how we i
know both of us live our lives this way
now is we do carry inexplicable weight
and it's we're just here to make
everybody else's lives better and and
what do we how do we make
the the families who've borne the cost
lighter and better and how do we help
the nation better learning from the
things that we've learned
uh
one of the really heartbreaking things
in the book that you write about was
you're you're going to
i guess were you part of the caico team
no i was home um you know on post
deployment leave but but in in virginia
beach and so being such a family friend
we were we were of course you know we
were one of some of the few
in the house yeah and you're talking
about on your way
to let you know his wife and his family
know when it happened you you you called
us a child psychologist and you you
asked
you said do we tell his daughter now the
truth of what happened or do we wait
until she's older so she can better
understand it and the psychologist says
you have no choice but to tell the truth
now
tough stuff i mean i'll never forget
being in the house with my wife and
daughter and i mean this merits a super
quick story it's you know when i was
overseas of course their family was
checking on my wife and daughter
and
one of the things before i came home
was that my daughter made a deployment
box that had 10 months worth of note
cards written out to her friend
my friend's daughter and they said
things like when you miss your dad
go into his closet take out a shirt of
his put it on and pretend it's a hug
you know no notes like that to say
here's how you're going to get through
the deployment
and so then you know just a month later
or so
me being there and seeing the deployment
box that she had told me about
which neither my wife nor i gave her the
direction to go do that that was her
entirely on her own and um sometimes you
know the the kids and the wives and the
spouses never get enough credit for for
as strong as they are but being in that
room
and i'll i'll still never forget her
screams
you know he said he'd come home and
and then more importantly like my
daughter being there and and consoling
her friend who had just lost her dad
it's these are
these are weighty things man makes you
grow up fast
[Applause]
how much longer after that did you
decide you were gonna you're gonna
retire
i was really close at that point i was
weighing it pros and cons in my head
that's not what influenced me in any way
i um i
made i actually frankly can't recall if
it was
how soon after that i made the decision
but
you know it ultimately was about
continuing to make a difference and and
i was i was at year 20 and after being
commanding officer of a team
i just felt like there's so much more to
do in life and
while it's awesome to be a seal and i'd
already been privileged to run meetings
in the situation room and like what am i
going to do like another six years and
return to attend the meetings that i've
already run
you know so i was like let me just pivot
and go
spend a chapter of my life in the in the
private sector which i'm 10 years into
now and have been really fortunate and
learned a ton and
and uh at some point
in my life i'll return
in some capacity to serve this nation
and
and i'm not sure what what form or
fashion that will take i really have no
idea i just know that when you're open
to service it will find you and the ways
we serve now are
genuinely doing things like writing
books and trying to make a difference
for gold star communities and and just
continuing to
to elevate the conversation
how was your transition when you retired
i i know people asked me that time that
question a lot and and
i always give the advice of like hey
when you get out you need a new mission
because
you you've been on mission
supe hyper focused on this one thing for
your whole life for everything from how
to freaking put your web gear together
in the most efficient way so your
magazines are in the right place for an
offhand draw like all those little
things that we were focused on for 20
years and then you get you go up through
the ranks where now you're focused on
how can my platoon do this better how
can i task you to do this better for you
it's how can i do this better for my
team how can i better support them and
then one day
in one day you clean out your locker and
you're a civilian
uh
and i always tell guys hey man you gotta
find a new mission and it sounds like
you got on mission pretty quick uh when
when you got out did you did you already
have that uh did you already have jobs
set up when you retired
yeah i i did i was again i've been very
fortunate because i had exposure that
that few people are privileged to have
whether it was the white house fellows
program or two years of of of a pretty
reputable graduate school
and so you know i i
i didn't know what i would do when i
made the decision to retire but i um i
had a lot of conversations to try to go
find that thing i had great mentors
um and ultimately you know had had
offers at goldman sachs and at jp morgan
and at bridgewater the hedge fund where
i ultimately went
a good good really good friend of mine
dave mccormick who actually just ran for
senate in pennsylvania uh who was in the
bush administration in the the treasury
while i was at the national security
council but dave is a a good really good
human and really good friend and
just asked him for some advice and and
um
and
he ultimately created another option
that i wasn't trying to create and i
jumped into to bridgewater with him and
a couple of other really great leaders
and learned a ton there and that was my
first chapter so
look it it's really it can when you look
in the rear view mirror with transition
you can say oh it must have been really
easy no way man it's super freaking hard
like because we're all planners
you know in the teams we're not like
we're not letting life just happen to us
we're planning life and this is an
element of time when you're like it
takes patience to for the plan to come
together
it's not like you can plan harder and
create things to happen in 12 hours and
and man i'm bad at a lot of things but
patience is definitely one of my week's
weak spots
you have this uh this section which i
think kind of wraps up
um
some of your transition here
you say this i hear the question all the
time how did you manage to move from the
military to the government to the
private sector when those arenas arenas
are so different from each other
my answer is to premise the challenge or
challenge the premise of this question
of course there are different different
details different specifics but the
truth is in my experience all high
stakes organizations and all high-stakes
decisions
are pretty much the same
the concrete knowledge you need is the
easy part anyone can learn that but the
details don't matter if you don't have
the right process and if you do have the
right process you can go anywhere it's
why strong leaders are able to jump from
one industry to another one organization
to another
so that's what you did applied your your
decision making process your
your lessons learned from the military
you applied them to the the government
sector i guess uh and then to the to the
civilian sector
um so you did bridgewater for a few
years
and then you ended up
actually entering the another business
right with with cognizant yep and then
what was that experience like well first
of all bridgewater is a phenomenal place
four years it is it is uh a crucible of
um of of talent that is all trying to be
more talented and do great things in in
markets and ultimately how to manage the
company so that they can outperform in
markets and the mission is very simply
to figure out what's going on in the
world and how to how to capitalize on
that for for their own investors you
know
police
retirements and teacher retirements and
and you know sovereign wealth funds and
things like that so i like the mission
of figure out what's going on in the
world right it's it's it's a large state
yeah it was so um that they do quite
well over their bridgewater very well
and and um and so but but after you know
four years or so three and a half four
years i was ready to pivot and a really
good friend of mine started a company
called cognizant he spun them out of
dun and bradstreet 25 at the time 25
years ago and or 25 years prior and then
they had an activist investor take a
billion six position in the stock and
start agitating and and i just called
them and said hey man here's what you
need to be thinking about just this this
and this and that the other thing
and he said mike just come help me come
help me run the company and i was like
i've never been in a large public
company and i was like look let me bet
on myself this is risky i'm not sure i'm
going to be great at this but i'm going
to go figure it out and it it's what you
just read in the book and and honestly i
think it i did very well there and
and i've continued to
you know pivot i'm now running global
operations and transformation and
and uh security and real estate etc for
for vmware it's a a large
software company and
with with very public news right now
about
a potential acquisition or an
acquisition again very public knowledge
and vmware is an awesome organization in
so many different ways and and just
bringing the same exact you know
skill set if you will
to vmware but with some of the knowledge
that you've that i've learned along the
way in the 10 years so it's a
combination of specific knowledge but
also you know the the management skill
of seeing
forests and trees but definitely both
yeah we've been my company echelon
font's been working with vmware we've
worked with vmware a decent amount um
but the fun thing is for me the first
time i worked with them was telling them
hey i used to carry vmware stuff in the
field and hook it up to my satellite uh
radio and make columns and they were all
pretty stoked and they got a good
veteran community there really strong
vmware so awesome company well it you
know and i forgot to mention the
i i know that the team thought
incredibly highly of your and and
echelon fronts leadership and and uh
instruction and
motivation and inspiration everything
that you are that you espouse has made a
huge positive impact on people and
whenever that that finished up i think
about a week ago or something like one
of them was the most recent was about a
week ago i got eat multiple emails
saying hey this guy's awesome everything
from like people who know that we know
each other and others like hey you ever
heard of this willing guy
yeah
yeah i heard of him
right so you got that going on
in the civilian sector that that chief
digital transformation officer
uh and at the me in the meantime you
know you mentioned giving back
and
you are giving back and one of the
things that
that you're doing which is incredible
is you this book that we've been reading
through today this book which is called
never enough um
you've taken all the prophets from this
book all the prophets from this book
and you are very specifically
giving the profits to gold star families
and very specifically
in order to pay off their mortgages
and this is you know home ownership is
not only
the american dream but it's also
the american nightmare when you've got a
mortgage to pay or when you don't have a
place to live or free if that comes
under pressure there's just there's just
a you know your home is your castle
and so this idea and i'm not sure quite
how you came you probably came to the
conclusion the way i just spoke through
it which is listen
if there's anything we could give a gold
star family the best thing we can give
them in terms of security and peace of
mind
is to say hey you can you don't have to
worry about where you're going to live
forever and so that's what you're doing
with this
and you know it's funny i was asking you
well like is there a website we can put
out or anything you're like nope it's
not it's it's you you don't even want to
spend money on a website you're like 100
it all goes to
buying these houses for gold star
families and i personally know some of
the people that you've done this for
again i can't imagine a better gift to
give a gold star family than
the absolute peace of mind of here's a
place for you to live and security for
the rest of your life how did you get to
that how did you get to that goal
well thanks for sharing that i really
appreciate that because that is really
you know multiple goals with never
enough one is to elevate the
conversation but a very very tangible
one is to literally pay off mortgages
like you described and just from seeing
firsthand the situations where
you know the the government doesn't
really cover nearly as much as as you
would expect in in a situation where
there's somebody killed in action or who
dies by suicide
and i just
felt like there's a gap in the community
there's plenty of fishing trips and and
mental health outlook like all very very
good things
but the most fundamental thing
is for these families not to feel the
pressure of needing to move from the
communities that have hugged them for
the previous 1 or 15 years of their
lives and to if you could you imagine
being a gold star widow all of a sudden
not that any of none of them make that
choice nobody wants that title
and um and being pressured to leave your
community like it's unfathomable to me
and so
i i just really was fired up that we
don't do more and so at this point we've
very very confidentially paid off six
mortgages and i'm on a drive to do more
and
ultimately alleviate this burden for for
really every one of these families that
has experienced this and i wish we could
wave a magic wand and do all of them all
at once but look it's it's um
it's it's really what drives me in one
of the ways that that i try to no i mean
that i am giving back
and if people want to help that cause
it's real simple
go and buy this book that's that's how
you help this cause hey look will you
get awesome lessons cool you get some
cool stories yes you will but
you will you'll be able to help out
these gold star families so
freaking outstanding um
you're also you're also involved with
the national medal of honor museum so so
tell me what's going on with that yeah
great we i'm on the board of a museum
that the nation hasn't built
so
about four years ago i got asked to give
somebody some advice there was something
that was a small local effort in south
carolina long story short uh they this
person asked me to join the board i said
you know like all of us are we're too
busy don't have time excuse blah blah
blah blah
and um and then
for personal reasons after sharing a
story back and forth
i said okay you've got me i'll join the
board on one condition
we get to fire everybody who's on the
board and we're going to make this thing
go national
so we've raised at this point 165
million dollars we've got about 60
million more to go we bro it took us
three years but we worked through
concept to city selection new york city
offered us governors island and
washington dc offered us a spot in the
mall
we ultimately did a bake off between
those plus denver and arlington texas
we chose arlington texas we're building
the museum right next to at t stadium
we've got an incredible board we've got
all of the ex-presidents um with the
exception of um of president trump uh
mostly from a timing perspective uh you
know we're
we're um we have great momentum this is
irreversible at this point of course uh
not surprisingly the the ceo of the
museum is my swim buddy that we've
talked about chris cassidy he's a
phenomenal american you know seal
astronaut and now ceo of this museum and
what we're really doing with this is
we're on a mission to inspire america we
will
we will take the lessons that the medal
of honor recipients uh have um that that
they espouse the character the values
etc
and and talk about that to make the
nation greater and the vision is for
you know some young kid to see the
brits libinski and what he did and learn
about his character values or you know
strike brit's name and replace it with
any recipient and say
how do i you know i'm seeing this little
third third grade situation develop i
see a girl being bullied on the school
yard how do i step in and go make this
situation right
that is what we we want to stop that or
school shootings or or or having the
bravery the courage to step in during a
school shooting and and stop the
shooting from happening or just to make
the make our nation stronger and better
and the the premise is really to inspire
america we will open
in about a year and a half
we haven't completely determined our
opening date but this will be one of the
nation's if not the i should say the the
premier museum for the nation that will
tell the stories of the roughly 3 500
recipients and 64 living recipients
many of them many of whom you personally
know and and just get their stories out
there yeah that's that's just awesome i
mean just the idea of
giving people uh
examples to read about and to be
introduced to that they can try and
follow in their footsteps at least be
inspired by and yeah that's just that's
just phenomenal um
a while ago maybe a couple i guess it
was maybe a year and a half two years
ago you you're like hey you shot me a
text hey you know we're looking for a
ceo of this uh
of this uh
of the medal of honor museum thing if
you know anybody let me know and i was
like racking my brain a little bit um i
definitely couldn't give you i couldn't
have given you a candidate as good as
chris cassidy yeah so you that's that's
that's an awesome guy to to to take the
to take the lead on that
and so did they did they start
construction already yes
was that when you were you doing the
groundbreaking ceremony when we were
both cross paths we missed each other in
the hotel by whatever an hour or
something march 25th is congressional
medal of honor day and that's the day we
broke ground we had president bush we
had just we had a
lot like 17 or 18 of the living
recipients there and yes that's when we
we came like minutes from linking up
with each other
well that's awesome um
does that bring us up to date on your
life right now yeah absolutely i mean
look
life is busy i can't sit still just like
you can't it's all about giving back and
and and i really do appreciate for
everybody out there this never pushing
never enough i i
promise you it's it won't disappoint
it's um it's not been extreme ownership
and therefore you can buy it a lot
cheaper on amazon so
but uh really do appreciate that great
support
and if people people want to find you
you have a website which is this is
mykays.com
you have instagram which is this is dot
mike hayes
you have twitter which is this is my
case and facebook the real my case
yeah so i don't know about you social
media was foreign to me about a year ago
but you know it's like like uh the
discomfort leaning into discomfort is uh
it's it's part of the new the new us
yeah it's it's definitely a very strange
thing to go from zero social media and
also
being anti-social media which we were
absolutely
had to be
what are you kidding me um but yeah uh
it was i guess it was a combination it
was it was
leif babin's wife jenna
who's like you got to get on social
media i'm like no i think life imitates
me now you know where i'm like no we
don't need it not doing it
and then jamie who who who's the ceo of
one of my companies is like you should
really do this i'm like i don't think we
need to and then tim ferriss who said
dude you better get on twitter or you're
an idiot i was like all right all right
a bunch of people that are telling me to
do this well what's real i have to say
you know what's really funny is of
course i i follow you and when you show
the four zero four thirty wake ups i
keep saying to myself i'm gonna get the
exact same watch and set it for one
minute earlier than you and take my
picture and just show that my i'm a
minute earlier than you every single
morning but uh i just haven't had the
energy to actually pull that off yeah
there's there's been some campaigns on
that i know andy's dumped for a while
was he what i forget if he was waking up
earlier
or he was doing something something like
that there's also a whole host of people
that that you know show their their
their watch at 10 42 in front of a box
of donuts and saying you know just got
after it um yeah but yeah so that's
where people can find you echo you got
any questions oh yeah real quick the you
know the fellowship program or your job
at the white house how often do you see
the president
it depends on what role you're in the
fellows get together a couple times
during the year with the president and
and have these candid off the record
conversations
and then if you're in a role like i was
at the national security council
sometimes it was three times in a week
and then it'd be a month without seeing
the president so a little bit varied
depending on what was going on in the
world interesting
that's your question yep that was easy
one man throwing softballs looking for
the high and inside fastball from ecco
charles
awesome uh mike any closing thoughts
nah just extreme appreciation i think
that's maybe the next uh extreme
appreciation besides extreme ownership
but uh just so
appreciate you and and all of our our
community and the the the nation for
helping elevate the conversation and
just recognizing that you know while we
were in the service we're ultimately all
here to serve each other and it takes
different forms and fashions and i just
encourage people to get off the sideline
and serve in whatever way makes the most
sense to to everybody listening and just
great appreciation for being here jocko
it's it's a real um special day for me
to be able to be it's shocking when we
go from you know water polo and killing
each other or you killing me in the pool
and then uh and this many years later
seeing where we both are in life it's uh
it's fun
kind of crazy man well uh speaking of
service
thanks for your service
to the country um to the nation to the
teams for what you've for what you've
done in your past and uh for what you're
doing today not only the civilian sector
but more important for what you're doing
uh today to take care of the families of
our fallen teammates so
thanks for coming out man sorry it took
us a while to get this together but
appreciate it man
all good brother it's my pleasure thank
you jocko thank you echo charles
and with that my case has left the
building
echo charles yes sir
key takeaways what do you got takeaways
the one key takeaway is kind of a
reminder something that i guess
yeah yeah i guess you talk about this
but anyway he said on
a few occasions process can save lives
the process
because and it's one of those things
where i'm personally i think i fall
victim to this a lot of the time where i
kind of i'm not used to having
for lack of a better term
where like you know that i don't have
any
many
i guess i do have some processes in
place but sometimes i can't put this i
can get distracted process on when to
take joint warfare dude yeah i'm not
saying i have all the processes for all
things okay for sure but i get
distracted from the process kind of easy
even though i know
that
if i stick to the process the chances of
success go way up exponentially
and i think that's kind of like and i
think about myself and i think how
generally speaking this can be the case
where if you allow that to happen like
whether it be because of stress because
of
you know just whatever kind of
distraction or whatever that's that's
how it works where if you just stick to
the process you can keep yourself out of
a lot of trouble even in
like hectic kind of situations yeah
yep and the dichotomy is
sometimes you got to get outside the
process you got to be flexible you know
it's
people literally say think outside the
box yeah so you got to know index when
does saving stick to the process and
when to
yeah make an adjustment yeah like the
process can be somewhat flexible but the
process is the process for a reason yeah
it's like okay so think of it in terms
of like jiu-jitsu for example like when
things start to get
you know let's say i'm rolling with you
yeah and you know you start turning up
the heat on me all of a sudden for
whatever reason that's going on your in
your head i can't get all panicky
and start going off
natural like instinct i gotta stick to
the technique yeah it's insane sure i
can turn on my urgency but i stick to
the process which is the technique it's
a good idea stick to what you've learned
like that and stuff that's a version of
the process yep but there's also a
situation where you might have to do
something that's
against the process look at jeffy glover
jeffy glover will do some wild things
yeah but if they're not it well then
again i can't read just mine yeah but
i will say this the stuff the creative
stuff that he does is all within the
realm of jiu-jitsu that he's either
learned or experimented
no because nowhere in jiu-jitsu does it
say like oh turn your back nowhere and
it doesn't say that anywhere well that's
his he might say it now i would say this
and i'm not saying you're wrong
necessarily but this is what i'm what
about pete degree going for risks all
the time okay so that's still that's
still jiu-jitsu though this is what i'm
saying so think about this no one was
telling him like i focus on the rest um
put it this way they're not focused on
wrestling they don't do that no one said
that they don't do that because they get
distracted or taken out of their game
they do that
voluntarily as part of the game yeah it
seems outside the process though is all
i'm saying maybe that is within their
process maybe their process i'm telling
you no there's no process in jiu jitsu
seven years ago that said hey turn your
back on the person's on the person
there's no no one that said that do you
predict jeffy glover just did it i know
you can't read jeff's fine or pete the
greek or anyone for that matter but
would you say yes or no would you say
that turning his back
done out of creativity do you think
that's part of his process
i didn't say it wasn't part of his
process as a part of the process
all right so cause you said trust the
process and what i'm saying is okay your
process and how about that okay trust
your process hey if there's a process in
place i'm saying if there's a process in
place go ahead
uh trust it yep
to a significant degree too significant
okay now
what i'm saying don't get distracted
meaning don't go on like if you start
going all crazy hard
is it beneficial for me to involuntarily
go all crazy hard back yeah like that's
you're making me get all specific over
here with the and his and all this other
stuff
i'm doing the best i can
right on ah no point now right on though
okay i'm
trying to
trust i'm trying to trust the process
myself are you trying to make a point
i'm trying not to ridicule it too hard
uh yes there is process that's why we
have standard operating procedures right
and you got to stay within those
standard operating procedures to your
point
a lot of the times yeah but you can't
get stuck in them so what complacency
distraction panic these are all things
that can make you deviate from the
process yep and then which kind of go
goes along to my secondary thing take
away it which is how and you guys well
you say this a lot all the time too it's
like staying calm and really make it a
point to stay calm
which kind of can be rolled into the
process right
not only is it part of the process
potentially
it helps you stick to the process once
you speak
so we're sticking to the process
speaking of sticking to the process get
yourself a subscription to it joint
warfare let's say super krill yeah okay
so the process is where we're main and
here's the thing too this is important
follow me
so in life life process no matter if
you're no matter what your job career
whatever you have certain things in life
that if you do stick to don't get
distracted complacent or panic about
these things are going to benefit you in
life uh not only exponentially
indefinitely
working out
reading and getting smarter keeping an
open mind doing jiu-jitsu doing
jiu-jitsu yes part of that game for sure
so when you work out
get yourself some supplements to help
you
yeah working outside easy all the time
not only can you help you work out it
can help you keep working out because
let's face it you can get jammed up yes
you can so the process is work out eat
good take relevant supplements
and i do say relevant because that's
something it's not nothing
some people take your relevant
supplements in my opinion so take
relevant supplements you stick to that
process now you're on the right track
there you go jockofield.com get yourself
some of those relevant supplements it's
true not what do you call the other
supplements irrelevant not irrelevant
supplements yes you didn't vary too much
on your vocab there were relevant
irrelevant which is fine correct you
know we talk about effective ineffective
you're doing the same thing it's cool
authorized you're staying with the
process
uh jacofuel.com you can check it out at
wawa you can get the drinks by the way
this is probably worth saying right now
we got all new flavors coming out not
only new flavors but the old flavors
which let's face it
some people didn't like that much
we'd redid them all and i'll tell you
what they're all amazing now and i don't
say that lately this isn't like
you won't find me in the past saying oh
try this it taste try our try jocko
discipline go drink it tastes amazing
you wouldn't hear me say that before
because it wouldn't be true
it tastes good and maybe to me some of
them taste pretty amazing but i wasn't
throwing out that blank blanket
statement
blanket statement right now
the new drinks
taste amazing
and that's a bold statement but i'm
making it reformulated um
so check those out they're kind of
hitting the stores right now
so as the as the old drinks run out yeah
the new drinks are coming in
so is there a way to tell which one is
the the
here you will be
in like a month but we we have to use up
the old can so the old cans right now
starting maybe like this week the old
cans have the new heat in them but how
do we know and they won't know you don't
know you'll know what's going to taste
the experience when you're tasting
you're like damn dragon wasn't lying
about that this tastes amazing
that's what you're going to get
so check out those check it out at wawa
check out the vitamin shop vitamin
shop's got all this stuff too um so
there you go let's get some of that you
probably saw me down at the did you see
me at the factory i saw the video video
okay then you saw me at the factory
originusa.com making stuff in america
the highest quality
the best gear is what you need pair of
jeans you need a pair of jeans
yes okay where are you going to get them
origin are you going to get them from
someplace that utilizes slave labor i
would prefer not to yes how about you
don't yeah don't do that i don't have to
anymore yeah that's true that's correct
originusa.com get yourself a ghee yeah
you can wear a ghee that feels good
that's a weird thing right it's a weird
because can it can a ghee have a feeling
yeah oh yeah yes sir okay well it does
isn't it nice when it feels good yes and
you can uh focus on the jiu jitsu part
of the the experience yeah not on the
discomfort of your gui yeah the third
man in the in the match yeah it's you
against your opponent and against your
shitty old geese
now it's you
and your ghee against your opponent your
opponent has to wear this old crappy
ghee that's already bothering you brutal
no i don't have to do that you can have
the ghee on your side it's true get the
key on your side that's my message
go to originusa.com for some of that
it's true there you go also when you're
on the path you want to represent go to
jacquelinestore.com this is where you
can get your t-shirts your hoodies light
and heavy by the way not super happy
we'll say regular hoodies and then
you're like
come on bro
the more and more people that acquire
these lightweight hoodies the more and
more good feedback
uh i get from them
there's such thing as light hoodie uh
environments and weather
concur a little bit also we have a
little thing called the shirt locker
okay recently we've been getting heavy
positive feedback from the shirt locker
design so what it is is if you don't
know which most people do but if you
don't
new shirt new shirt design every month
subscription automatically comes to you
um very creative i guess for lack of a
better term but yes very good positive
feedback in that one so check that one
out at choco store if you want if you
want if you want to get a cool
shirt to wear that not many people are
going to have
because you know you know sometimes like
uh
someone go a girl goes out to a party
and there's another girl there and
they're wearing the same dress yes and
it's drama man this is drama or as my
daughters would call it you know what
that is this is t
what do you a t t no t it's just t it's
t
there's a meme of like someone drinking
tea and it's sort of like drama
so you can say that's t
you see you're not caught up no no no
you don't you're not hip like me i don't
see the correlation between tea and
drunk it comes from a meme mm-hmm
where someone's drinking tea oh uh
yes kermit the frog is drinking tea and
it represents drama okay so i'm pretty
sure the me i don't know i think you
might
be right but maybe the re
so the frog
is drinking tea and he says it'll all
the meme will always say something
something something but that's none of
my business
drinking drinking tea so yeah so you
will get uh let's say uh what group is
this millennial no it's lower than
millennial what's
not lower but what's
younger than millennial i think it's z
so gen z i think they'll say oh and they
won't say tell me the gossip
they'll say tell me the t do you not
know this
this is news to me yes okay oh so no i
did not know that that's good that's new
that's good cool hello so yeah so there
you go there you go if you want the tea
get a good t-shirt you know right you're
saying you know what you're saying when
girls show up to the party and
somebody's wearing the same album yeah
that's some tea for your
there's drama right so when you get when
you're part of the shirt locker no one's
showing up with the same t-shirt as you
well actually technically if they do
you're kind of like duh you're kind of
down yeah no tea well here's the thing
it's kind of cool
the tea scenario we might drink over the
small country when you do that you show
them with the same sherlock or t-shirt
and you're like what let's go let's take
over this nation start planning
plotting no that so technically the uh
the female
drama when there's the same outfit in
the same location is opposite with males
it's opposite oh okay that's like the
thing this is why you and carrie when
you show up and you're wearing the same
t-shirt you're like oh yeah fist bump
yes
yeah you will bro like
dave burke good deal dave same deal show
up with the same t-shirt but i'm telling
you like if you went to the okay if you
went okay you're wearing this you know
no matter what you're wearing you go
somewhere and someone else is wearing
the same thing you don't feel like oh
you're wearing that you kind of feel
it's a positive feeling
so i'm saying like you're a sociological
expert over there either way the word
shirt locker shirts jaw uh jockle store
stuff
no exception you're gonna feel you're
gonna feel the camaraderie that's what
you're gonna feel no see speaking of
subscribe subscribe to the podcast don't
forget about jacquelineground.com
appreciate the support over there don't
forget about the youtube channel that's
true if you want to see some
some just really sort of award-winning
assistant directing happening
you can come and check out some of my ad
activities amazing it's incredible
actually there's some new stuff on there
on youtube
like this the top gun review like some
kind of one-off videos yeah pretty solid
the top gun one the
i put some underground clips on there
too yeah for the people just so they can
get a little what's going on sometimes
some things are important yeah that they
need to know about so so check that out
psychological warfare on mp3 platforms
flipside canvas dakota meyer speaking of
medal of honor recipients dakota meyer's
medal of honor recipient he's badass
he's funny as hell i have conversations
sometimes with dakota where we're
laughing so hard neither one of us can
talk
this is rare
uh and he also has a company called
flipsidecanvas.com where he puts cool
stuff to hang on your wall so if you
want something cool to hang on your wall
cool you might as well get it from
dakota meyer books hey first of all
never enough by mike hayes check that
book out listen all the profits for that
book all the profits go to gold star
families
so just get the book and are there
lessons learned yes are there cool
stories yes
will you help out gold star families yes
you will so check out that book only cry
for the living by holly mckay
check out that book if you want to know
what was going on in iraq and syria
uh then i got a bunch of books that i've
written
you can check those out as well
i have a leadership consultancy called
echelonfront where we teach leadership
two companies
and leadership is how you solve problems
inside of organizations so if you need
help there go to
echelonfront.com we get we got the
muster coming up there's like a couple
more seats left i don't even know if i
should say anything because it might be
sold out by now if you want to come to
the monster go to ashlandfront.com the
next one is june 15th through the 17th
denver colorado i know it's late but if
you want to come come and check it out
we also have an online training academy
if you want to learn how to lead
you don't necessarily have to leave
your office your house you can learn to
lead online and you cannot just learn to
lead others because that's not what it's
all about some of it's about that some
of it's about how to lead yourself how
to make good decisions for you
how to be on the path
so check out extremeownership.com for
that
and if you want to help some service
members
active and retired you want to help them
get medical treatments that they might
need
that the government doesn't pay for for
whatever reason there's a bunch of
reasons why they might not pay for it
check out america's mightywarriors.org
that's mama lee organization mark lee's
mom
check that out also remember
heroes and horses.org micah fink up
there in the wilderness
taking people out on horses and letting
them re-learn how to live
so check that out and once again don't
forget about never enough
and helping out gold star families not
have to worry about a mortgage or a
place or a house or a home or a castle
because that's what mike's giving them
so that's awesome
and if you want to find mike hayes on
social media this
he's at
this is my case you can find him on
instagram twitter
um facebook also echo's on there i'm on
there echoes out of the charles i'm at
jacqueline
hey and when you get there just just
watch out
because you know the algorithms sneaking
up on you
thanks once again to my case for joining
us and for your service and sacrifice
for our great nation
appreciate you coming by and thanks to
the rest of our selfless military
members out there right now on the front
lines
protecting us and protecting our way of
life we kind of take it for granted it's
real easy
to take it for granted it's real easy
but we're not taking it for granted here
also thanks to our
service the service of our police and
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service all the
first responders that are out there
doing the same thing
sacrificing
to protect us here at home
thank you
and everyone else
you know i
you know i know
sometimes you've been on the grind for a
while right the grind you've been
working you've been staying focused and
holding the line
and at some point
maybe you feel like you're there
like you got there like you made it
but that's a good time when you feel
like that that's a good time to remember
that that's
not enough
it's never enough we can all do a little
more
work a little harder be
a little bit better
so
reload
and recharge and go out there every day
and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko